hello everybody oh my god okay we're gonna have to restart
the game already we're off to a good start okay give me a
second i gotta restart the game i was like oh wait no okay
all right let me restart this real fast let me restart this
oh my god oh my god okay I'm experiencing right now, but
it's a little bit of a problem, and what it is, okay, I
might have to do this to, oh, God, oh, God, okay, give me a
sec, okay, let's plug in my controller, how's my controller
not responding, I'm a mess, okay, hello, controller, okay,
okay, guys, give me a sec, oh, God, you don't see what I'm
seeing, but it's so bad, you know i'm happy you're not
seeing what i'm seeing right now but basically what's going
on is that okay did this fix it oh i think you fixed it okay
so what i was seeing was that um um it's like there was like
flickering going on but like it's not the flickering that
you guys are used to seeing, it's the flickering where
basically, I see myself flicker on the screen.
Like, my skin suit.
I see my skin suit flickering on and off on the screen
because it's like trying to be, like, the dominant window.
So I have to be like, okay, I have to do full screen.
I can't.
I was like, oh, thank God.
You're not, it was terrible.
It was actually so bad.
Why is it not controller?
Why is it?
Do I click continue to be on controller?
Guys, this is why.
This is what I mean when I said.
This is.
Oh wait.
Here you go.
Control setup.
Why am I not on controller?
Hello?
Why am I?
PC.
Please.
Wait.
What's like, what's like the, uh, the thing that boots up
the, the steam thingy?
PC, please.
Why aren't you on controller?
Guys.
We have a new PC, but I'm already a mess, guys.
I'm already on a mess.
Normal size, fancy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Well, look on the bright side, Ducky.
I don't know what it is, but look at it anyway.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is, this is a new PC, but like, everything is so new.
This is why change is so hard.
Oh, oh, wait, controller.
Okay, I have to restart it.
Okay, we did it.
Guys.
See guys?
I can, I can adapt.
That's when you know I'm a gamer.
All right.
So, um, I think sound guys, sound guys, you're here.
Let me know if everything sounds okay.
If everything sounds okay in chat, you don't have to type to
me on Discord because, like, I'm too lazy to, you know, tab
to my Discord.
So anyway, for those who forgot what happened last time,
what happened was that we found out that this lady right
here should not be in our country because she was actually
an illegal, an illegal immigrant.
was actually from forest look i look that's what they said
okay they literally called her that so i'm just repeating
what she said uh i'm literally i'm literally repeating like
what she's what they said about her so yeah i was very
surprised i was honestly an illegal Yeah, I was very
surprised they said that.
But, like, that's where the story is going towards.
So, she is actually from Forestland.
And, uh, and, yeah.
And then what was crazy was General was like, oh my God, she
shouldn't be here.
She should go back to Forestland.
I'm like, what, what am I playing?
I'm just, I'm just like, what?
What am I... What am I playing?
I thought...
Where were...
I feel like...
Yeah, the English...
I'm glad I'm like...
I'm glad I played the English dub because I don't have to
read.
But also, what the fuck is going on with the...
English dub?
Like...
Also, Aquinium.
Also, Raoul...
really loves Aquaniums for some reason.
Uh, or thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Maybe the real scuff and the real controller was the friends
we made all along the way.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So yeah, that's the update.
That's literally like, honestly, that's literally it.
That's everything we need to know about this game so far.
Uh, all right.
We gotta go to here.
Let me see if I can remember how I play this game.
Okay, there you go.
And then wee.
Okay, I still remember how to play this game.
That's good.
That's good to know.
That's really good to know that I still remember.
Oh my god, and I still remember that I gotta kill all the
animals.
I mean, you know, not kill, but like, you know, they're
invasive species.
Okay, guys?
Guys, if Florida is allowed to, like, kill all the iguanas
in their area, in their local area, then I should be
allowed.
allowed to like get rid of the invasive species here uh are
you sure i'm pretty sure these raptors are not oh that's an
alpha raptor i'll leave uh i'm pretty sure i'm pretty sure
these raptors are not uh are not native to sandland there's
no way yeah you guys didn't know oh you guys didn't watch my
shadow of the classes uh stream yeah uh florida has an
iguana problem right now uh where like iguanas are
considered an invasive species and because of that uh
florida has put out a decree out for all floridians to like
you know kill any iguanas they see on site or like eat them
i guess what
is this oh this is where like ral committed like murder a
war crime
is worse than i expected how many invasive species does
florida have like a lot it's florida guys it's florida
that's right it caused the massive explosion that
obliterated everything in the area and the one who pulled
the trigger on that bomb it's you right Carl, you committed
a war crime.
Was the commander of the Royal Army Tank Corps.
Me.
Yeah, and not Florida.
Sandland's not so great anymore, is it?
Maybe Forestland was better.
I wanted you to see for yourself just how dangerous Aquanium
is.
That sounds like a perfectly good reason.
doesn't it but really I think I was just afraid you're a
pretty tough human though what are you scared of having to
face up to this irreversible crime of mine all by myself but
I'm glad we came now I'm all the more certain that
technology is too dangerous for humans yeah and that bread
guy wants to get his hands on loads of it for something Oh
my god, don't let the Valorant players find out about
Aquinium.
He'll be completely unstoppable if he gets his hands on
anymore.
How will I save my father?
Oh, whoa.
Okay, I guess you're not as important.
Father, you have a dad?
No way!
Oh my god!
dad why is that a surprise I don't understand okay I boosted
the volume up a little bit how is that possible you mean you
didn't come out from self replication like those lizards do
you guys know there's a type of lizard that just clones
itself literally the females pretend to bang each other to
replicate like male males and then they just cloning
themselves Kroa
oh so you've heard of me Kroa how did he hear it of him what
the fuck is this guy can I go to forest land yet I'm tired
of sad forest land armies general if you know who I am let's
cut to the chase I'm gonna need you to hand over that a
quenium to me this is my first time seeing a demon i'm close
orders are a pain no it's elvis guys
i'll take you on anytime anywhere don't move i won't give
you another warning
what am i doing what am i doing Man, thief, Anne, don't bite
your tongues.
What?
Oh!
To shoot the humans!
Almost had me.
But playtime's over.
Wrong.
I'm just getting started.
What?
What did I do?
I just punched the floor.
what oh my god there was a okay who cares about these guys
bro what be as above you may survive a fall but they're
people they're humans they are flesh bags that doesn't mean
they will survive and then everybody does mistakes they give
the super chat thank you thank you no kidding huh where's BL
that's mean I got banned in my mouth
anyway where are we oh we're like in another little temple
thing ruins it looks like I never thought all of this was
under our feet we don't have time for sightseeing General
Kroa and his troops can't be all that far.
Let's find a way out before we're spotted.
Alright.
We gotta get out of here.
Oh, this is the second ruins that I have to do.
Looks like ruins.
Human ruins from long ago.
Oh my god.
Am I gonna find like...
An Apple Watch?
Because this is like in the future, right?
So, like, am I...
Am I going to find, like, an Apple Watch?
And, like, PCs and waifus here?
All right, let me boost up the volume.
I boosted up the volume a little bit.
Also, I can, like, upgrade it.
Yeah, because this is apparently, like, in the distant
future, like, Star Wars.
Like, how Star Wars is in the distant future.
Sandland is, like, in the distant future.
All right, we got upgrade.
Raises B as a boss attack when HP is low.
My HP is never low, though.
That's the thing.
increase potency of the rush special uh increase deployment
speed for okay we should get uh we should raise the darkness
oh I have not been leveled guys I think I've not been
leveling up guys
I just realized there's like there's a lot of things I have
not been leveling up I want to get that so I can get the top
one the BSO buff thing okay we have like a lot of ally
points to.
I feel like, uh, I don't really need to get items.
I just need to upgrade Raul.
Because, like, his tank shit was actually so, was actually
really good for me.
Uh, I guess, like, dropping more items, maybe?
Yeah, we need items.
Never mind.
We need inventory.
Uh, all right.
Apple AR contact lens.
They give us super chat moore thank you thank you did you
guys hear about the you know like what is that device that
device where you where you put it on um and it ended up
being like a oh my gosh i'm trying to remember what this
device was it was so the trailer was so fucking dumb it's
apparently like in an i like a uh a universal translator or
it can act as a universal translator uh Where you like wear
it and then when you're talking it translate what you're
seeing in real time But then it ended up being like a
fucking scam Because I remember the trailer was so fucking
stupid and it was like some I'm gonna beat you up.
Oh my fist is stronger than you Uh, what's up I have an
exoskeleton when my fist can beat the shit out of you The AI
cliff thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah the AI cliff thing It had a really dumb
name.
Can't remember what it was called.
Yeah, it had a really stupid... Okay, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna bring a tank in here.
It doesn't matter.
Give me a sec.
It was scorpion.
Okay, he's dead anyway.
Oops.
It's okay.
The humane.
Was it the humane?
Oh my god, please don't be too fat.
No!
Somebody close the hatch!
Raul and Anne, you do not need to look out Raul.
and M.
Literally, sit inside.
Bro, sit inside and close the hatch.
Like, what the fuck?
I hate my team.
Oh, I am able, oh my god, I hate you guys so much.
Why can't you just close the door?
I don't understand.
You don't need to have it open.
Okay, we have to go this way, I think.
Oh, no, that's just loot.
It doesn't, it doesn't, if you close the hatch, that's the
thing.
It can't fit if you close the, that's what hatches are for.
If they made a door for it, you're supposed to be able to
close it.
Yay.
Guys, I realized, I realized today, yesterday, last night,
that I'd never posted my schedule on the community post.
So I bet a lot of my like YouTube viewers are like real like
the ones that don't follow me on Twitter are really confused
on when I'm streaming And they're just looking at like
They're like they're like looking at my waiting rooms to
figure out I realized I'd never post I've been so busy holy
shit Every day has been like a lot of work every day.
I also just realized I forgot to answer an important work
message.
Oops Oh, wait, where am I?
Did I not make it?
Oh, my God.
You mean this isn't a gorilla?
Yeah, for them, it's like gorilla week right now, and I was
like, oops.
Oops.
I knew I forgot something.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
Motorcycles are so hard to drive.
Okay, we don't care about these guys.
I just realized that these guys are, like, useless.
I don't even, like, I barely ever leveled up from them
anyway no there's a pothole what's the point of paying
taxpayer money and they don't fix this i can't believe it
the king takes so much money from me the king of sandland is
always seeking money from me and they don't fix the potholes
god damn it this is why the monarchy was a mistake why have
we not overthrown the a king yet i can't believe it it's a
ruin somebody should fix the potholes and the ruins oh my
god there's snakes let's take this fist oh shit i'm sorry
all right wait give me a sec give me a sec don't worry i'll
deal with you soon guys it's not overkill okay i need to get
off the tank now This is not overkill, okay?
Wait, there was nothing here!
Wait, the snakes looted my...
The snakes looted it!
I can't believe it!
They don't even have hands!
Okay, I really don't have to care about them.
I don't need to level up these...
Level up with the snakes.
It's just a distraction.
I can't believe it.
What are you gonna do with my items?
All I'm saying is that, like...
the king should be responsible with fixing the potholes in
the ruins as well also no matter how good of a of an
official you are somebody will complain about something and
that's me i'm somebody and i'm always complaining
yeah what happened i guess the classics never go out of
style No pointy stakes lining the bottom though.
At least they were humane enough not to impale us.
Oh, maybe there's monsters in the pit.
Seems like you spoke too soon.
So like the deaths won't be instant because that's what I
will do if I want to fucking kill somebody in game.
I knew it!
Might be in trouble here.
I knew it, but there should be more though.
I'm starting to think we'd have been better off fighting the
Forest Land Army instead.
You never even seen the Forest Land Army.
10 gift dishes that you thank you what are you doing prince
time to throw down
huh like i said time to fight quiet wait why you're telling
me what to do what is she doing is she said to be a speaker
you guys are scared oh my gosh she's a freaking freak she
talks to bugs goddamn forest lander this is why there's a
gate that separates between sand land and forest land
thank you please
incredible well i'll be plucked from the jaws of death by a
little girl They're literally bugs.
I can just send out a tank.
I know.
They must have been so scared of me that they ran off.
Typical forest people.
Go back to your trees.
Sandland people don't need oxygen.
We have sand.
And now water apparently.
So I don't know why we're still sandland.
Because we have water now.
Makes me wonder if there is a water then.
Like how deep does it go?
Water.
Tree huggers.
You think you're so much better than me just because you
have trees.
Well, we have we just have water now.
So yeah, how are you gonna how are you gonna survive when we
have the monopoly on the water?
Where the hell do I go?
Oh, it's this way.
Wait, how do I get up?
Oh, it's over here.
Okay.
Yeah, how do you want all your trees, Forestland, if we have
all the water?
A person couldn't fit through that crack.
Yeah, why would I want trees when we have sad and more sad?
I want to see Fire World True.
Yeah, sometimes I can hear what the animals and bugs are
saying.
What the fuck?
My...
Do all you guys know what they're saying?
It's like we can understand each other in a weird way.
You can communicate with animals?
Just like Prince's older sister, Lilith.
She had a similar power as well.
I have a sister?
What happened to her?
I had a sister, I think.
Where the fuck happened to Lilith?
Like, this is the first time I've heard about my sister.
No secret doors either, huh?
Wait, Biel's.
Your sister's name is Lilith?
Yeah.
That's funny.
Your sister has the same name as my mom.
What?
You're my niece?
Wait a minute.
I'm older than her?
what oh my god the plot twist oh that's it wait this was
such an important information that's it
are we not gonna talk about the fact that this could be my
niece like is this how we're okay i guess this is how we're
ending the conversation apparently
What do you mean?
I need clarification.
And what's your father's name, young lady?
Why do you want to know that?
I don't know.
Potentially you could be my niece.
Don't worry.
Just tell us.
Jam.
Bread and jam.
Wait.
Isn't the king of forest land named Jam?
Oh my god.
Your royalty?
Bread imprisoned my father.
Bread and jam.
oh my god this is a Toriyama I knew it you really are feed
princess Lilith's daughter what my mother was a thief you're
half demon hold on your father's king jam you're a princess
where are you thank you for the five gift the ships thank
you thank you dummy you just had to raise a rat Okay, we
were yelling long before this.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to scare you again.
I knew it.
That's the same power Lady Lilith had.
Uh-huh.
And I knew you smelled weird.
Oh, bro.
What the fuck?
That's not how you talk to women, Biazo.
You don't just say that.
How can you be so calm about this?
A human?
Marrying a fiend?
Whoa.
It happens.
Oh, wow.
I mean, people get freaky.
Anyway, that's not important.
This is my mom we're talking about.
If she was a fiend.
That's right.
You're one of us.
One of us.
Half human and half fiend.
Wait, but you don't have the... Why aren't you not pink?
I'm not that good.
But...
Why?
Is being a demon such a shameful thing to you?
Oh my god, you can't just ask somebody why they're not pink.
Okay, now that I know you're part of the family, I'm okay
with you being a forest lander.
Save it for later.
We have to think of a way out of here.
Look, we all can make an exception.
as she's family.
How about asking them if they know how to get out of here?
Sure.
Okay.
I can try, but don't get your hopes up.
Alright.
Let's see.
Alright, talk to those bugs.
Tell us how to get out of here.
Sorry for scaring you again.
We would like to leave ASAP.
Do you know way out wait then she's not an illegal alien
because like she's related to beezobab and beezobab clearly
has citizenship in sandland so it's fine because like lilith
was from sandland so she should have dual citizenship yeah
wish i could be as happy as you be have dual citizens why
are you not happy you should be happy that you're you're
you're half demon you get to live forever or not forever but
like half of forever
is it this way i think so oh yeah i mean this means i get
out yeah she has diplomatic immunity and she has dual
citizenship oh back here okay whoops how do I, whoops, oh my
god okay there we go how much is half of forever?
I don't know half of forever all right up we go I can't
believe it she was she was always allowed to be here
the floor might not hold us now just not walk that way just
walk the right side whoa okay how is okay this is not as
dangerous as i thought like what the fuck i literally can
just walk up
oh no oh my okay what the okay that was actually scary the
floor is fragile here too like that's not even as big as
like uh okay like i might as well just fall down it's just
faster it's literally just faster than running past the
fucking falling falling blocks all right fuck this and then
i'll just run over here and then i'll run over here there
you go this is actually a lot easier fuck that was.
Oh!
Or use the bike.
Sorry.
Guys, you know I don't listen.
I mean, I don't know how I'll ever... I did it.
I used the bike.
You have friends?
You mean the resistors?
The resistance.
Oh, this is where I had to go.
You have friends?
Not anymore when they fly.
Now you're a freaking...
I'm joking.
The thing is, this discovery just threw a wrench into
everything the resistance stands for.
Protecting the country from fiends.
What?
Bro, they're equally as racist.
They're racist against demons.
...justified his coup.
...
we all thought it was a lie that's why we kept fighting but
if my mother our queen really was a fiend oh my god that's
xenophobe oh sorry is it oh my god it calls the resistance
his whole raison d'etre into question wait the time
resistance was against demons bro what the like what is the
Lady Lilith would never enslave a man The soul of resistance
was about killing demons I'd like to believe you I would but
with my mom gone I'm sorry xenophobic Gone where What's my
sis been up to while all this is going on She's dead The
forest and army teams of brave heroes slew her sister is
dead too?
Huh?
That's ridiculous.
Yeah!
She's literally a demon.
How would they kill a demon?
Not even I could beat her.
Not once.
You say that.
No, I couldn't I couldn't find out if she's hot or not.
No way.
Feet, we're finding my sister.
Say no more.
you mean you're coming with me oh thank god yes i am yeah
please take me to forest land please we're dying from the
lack of oxygen you're coming too ralph absolutely i've got
to get that aquarium back i couldn't hope for stronger
allies what is this game what is this just to be Okay, I'm
not gonna lie.
The second half of the story is fucking wild.
I can't believe my big sis lost to someone.
Bro, I can't believe your big sis might be dead.
I'm stronger than me out there.
Shouldn't you be more...
You know...
worried about her there's no way how do you kill a demon
they'll just go back to hell and then you can like get them
back from hell right like how can you kill a demon if you if
they're already technically dead just like bring them back
from hell alright I don't really care to be fair about all
these monsters around me depends on the lore I guess like he
kill like japanese demons because this is based off of like
um japanese demons right so tech i guess you can because of
innu yasha that's like my that's that's my knowledge of like
yokai oh and yokai watch in innu yasha you can like my
source Oh wait, uh, B.
Okay, there has to be like, uh...
There must be like extra loot here or something.
Because why would there be like rocks covering this pathway?
Alright, oh, queen scorpion!
What the fuck?
Alright, what the heck is the queen?
Sorry, what the hell is that?
I'm still like self-censoring myself from Minecraft.
Ever since Minecraft.
I couldn't stop I couldn't stop the family friendly Alright,
this is easy though This is not too bad Oh my god, he hasn't
even hit me Bro, what the fuck You're just garbage You can't
even hit me You're too slow Alright, this is like the
easiest fight ever holy shit where are your children they
should put you in a home that's a lot of loot yay okay and
then well i can get off the thing i need to find this chest
there's stuff here oh nice okay there's oh my god there's a
lot of loot nice that just got 25 xp for that wait that's so
sad oh I got silver coin that I can give to Najin Boo.
Alright.
The thing is, the thing is, though, like, I think, like,
Toriyama helped write the second half of the story too.
So, it's actually, the second half of the story is so
fucking wild.
I really did not expect the story to go this way.
Why?
Oh, my God.
Like, oh, my God.
Wait, we don't have...
Wait, but, like, okay, to be fair, like, uh...
Wait, no.
I was never born in Forestland.
Am I allowed to be in Forestland?
Guys!
Is there...
Are there passports in this world?
Guys, are there passports?
No!
Is it this way?
Have I gotten this way before?
for a proud oh my god oh no guys we're illegally entering
forest land no what are you doing to me niece guys guys no
no snitches okay guys no no snitches okay guys all right how
do i get oh wait this way okay i got a lot bit lost in the
ruin Okay, no, it was not this way.
It was right here.
Alright.
Now, clearly there's, like, a passport system.
There's, like, immigration.
Because, like, the general was, like, wait a minute, you're
not supposed to be here.
You're from Forestland.
So clearly, there are, like, immigration rules.
From Forestland to Sandland.
Because, like, the general was not very happy about, like,
and being here by like non by like non-legal means and there
are citizenships between like different whoa whoops okay
maybe i need the bike here we go the manga is very short why
aren't you done yet that is such a wild state bro i already
passed the manga
all right let's see guys how do i jump okay okay press a
guys i'm trying to head to forest land this is why i'm not
done with the game yet this game is like 30 hours long guys
all right we made it
yay we made it wait this is another boss wait the ceiling is
collapsing oh my god oh my god please oh my god i went so
fast too that's it i'm using my legs i'm using my fucking
legs now now just walk over here oh wait wait oh wait you
can't cheese this anymore you actually have to be faster
they don't have platforms on the other side.
Oh.
Alright, look.
That was...
Okay, that was anti-climatic.
Here we go.
Alright, let's see.
Okay.
Maybe I'll walk from here.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Let me through.
Alright.
It's not my fault.
My bike is like 200 pounds.
Bro, that bike is not... Are you serious?
Are you serious?
Okay.
You had to destroy it, because there's no way I was faster
than the than the collapsible floor.
Guys, I don't know if you guys noticed, but my bike is made
of titanium.
Alright, here you go.
Made it.
Made it?
wait the check mark lied to me it said five meters wait now
it says 41 meters why is it lying to me oh wait but this is
like not from the checkpoint so i mean there's extra loot i
knew it thank god for the yellow all right is there an extra
loot over here oh mine to upgrade better dragoons and
dragoons all right okay now we made it oh my god I see the
outside oh my god how did you get here how did you get here
before me so you finally showed took you long enough she got
here before us certain ancient ruins might be more illegal
than illegal immigration no because if it were The British
Museum wouldn't be the British Museum.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha.
No way for you to run this time.
Hand over the Aquini.
Don't get any funny item.
Sounds like you've got a wrong one.
You're no match for us without being surrounded by your
troopers.
Wow.
Someone's real brave now that you've got me outnumbered.
Didn't know you were such a coward.
You...
Who are you calling a coward?
Me?
How dare you?
I killed a real person in game.
Wait, what?
Don't let...
Oh shit, wait.
Drive, Korra.
Oh wait, okay, I gotta kill him.
Okay, that's what a tank is for.
Alright, here you go.
Oh my god, why are you so fast?
It's okay.
Dude, he's way too fast.
What do you mean?
I literally have a tank.
Like, we're the same.
How do you stay still?
How?
I don't understand.
How is he so fast?
Okay, wait, wait.
What if I, what if I, like, destroy this?
Can't destroy this?
How do you stay still?
Wait, race?
I'm supposed to race him?
Oh, I have to anticipate the...
Oh!
You can shoot back!
That's messed up.
This is messed up.
He shoots back, guys.
I'm not used to people shooting back.
Okay, maybe we get a bike.
I'm gonna get a bike.
Okay.
Ugh.
How do I how do I stop him?
Okay, no, please.
Oh, what?
How does he hit me?
Oh shit, my bike.
Oh, what?
My bike.
Oh, guys, guys, it's on fire.
Guys, it's on fire.
Guys, it's not looking so good.
My bike is on fire.
Oh, I have to ram him.
is that it wait he's almost dead as i guys i know like some
it looks like he's almost dead okay i can't believe this
boss is actually difficult wait what if i said riole wait if
i hit him head on he takes so much damage holy shit he takes
so much wait i'm mtpsing you'd make a great recruit if you
weren't a demon wait i'm actually dpsing okay oh my god i'm
doing projectiles guys oh no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no okay we gotta send in the rio where's rio how do i
send it how do i send in rio i forgot guys how do i how do i
send in my extra help can you even keep up with my bot okay
it's all right you're like p-shooters oh lb lb vehicle
warfare ryle you do the thing is that all ryle that's a
fucking pillar ryle please ryle please ryle please for the
love of god ryle please why did you hit the pillar I can't
believe it No No I can't shoot I jammed it Oh my god he's
like hitting me Okay he's literally one hit I just need to
lead this Come on Oh my god he's literally one hit Okay Lead
no Yes
I did it That's right, now die.
Yay, Mernie!
What the fuck?
How?
Damn, she's strong.
You're a citizen of my beloved country.
country too okay
wait it was just that bro entire pillar landed on him what
happened to the rest of the pillar oh i see wanted to
deliver the finishing blow yourself yeah if the game would
let me you've earned the right josey they Thank you for the
super chat.
Thank you.
She's showing them FPS aiding skills.
She isn't.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They're saying you're under a fiend's spell, but it sure
doesn't look that way.
The demons I heard about in stories are nothing like you
guys.
You never even met a real demon before.
You're from Forestland.
We live in Sandland.
Just know it won't go like this next time what the fuck i
literally saved your life keep trying you'll never win their
generals are on a whole other level from the royal armies oh
yeah they actually have tanks that are fast is likely their
only match the forest land army is really something else i
gotta get out of here they don't scare me What do you mean?
They literally had a tank that's so fucking fast.
I'll have to get off.
God damn it.
Why do they make such small doors?
They're not tank accessible.
Where are my accessibility here?
Can't believe it.
Sometimes I just don't want to use my legs.
Repair time.
They'll self-under.
self-repair themselves by the way bls
i've been calling you bls but you're yeah that's what i'm
saying she's my niece don't go calling me yunk how old am i
then you've got to start calling her lady anne thief yeah
because she's royalty she's lilith's kid after all uh yes of
course but i mean after all we've been through okay this is
getting weird let's just stick with our old names i mean
yeah it's pretty weird that you're like my niece and
everything and that you're half demon hey old man why don't
we head into forest land what are like a a shitty like i'd
like to say What's the word?
Like, you know, she's half demon, and all she gets is she
can talk to fucking bugs.
Like, what is...
There's so many other cooler things she could get from being
half demon, but all she got was being able to talk to bugs.
Pushed yourself too hard, huh?
She's not demon strict.
She could barely fucking pick...
It was like one tablet of stone, and she was struggling
already.
that is not demon string that is like one eighth of demon
string you youngster it takes more than an epic adventure to
wear you out me and thief are older than you and we're not
one bit tired wait how old am i every rule i'm not older
than her i mean i am like the uncle but still like what can
i upgrade yet oh i can okay uh i wanted to use this one like
boost the specific use items uh when we want to raise xp i
like how we can still not upgrade anne like she's she's just
there like like she like follows us everywhere but like she
we can't she doesn't do anything she's just there she's like
the moral yeah she's like the moral Uh, moral support right
now.
Thanks, Anne.
I knew I could count on you.
Uh, so, uh, Parupo, thank you for the five gift of ships.
Thank you.
Do you think we'll ever explore all of Sandland?
No, please not.
God makes my head spin.
Please not.
When can I get to Forestland?
Guys, all I wanted to do is Forestland.
Oh my god.
Guys, it'll be fine.
Guys, I know my bike is on fire, but it'll be okay.
Where do I have to go?
Yeah?
Oh, I have to go to Spino.
I can't fast travel right now?
Oh, is it because I have, like, all these guys chasing me?
real.
Forestland has to be real.
Ants from Forestland and my sister is too.
It has to be real.
Okay, now I can fast travel.
Good thing we have this safe place to rest.
So, what was it you wanted to do?
Yeah.
Wait, why did we do all that?
Before we enter Forestland, I want to make sure we retrieve
all the Aquanium and Sandland.
You mean there's more?
There's more Aquanium?
I suspect so, but I can't say for sure.
I don't get it.
Sandland used two battleships in the Great War.
One of them was the Lysob Battleship, and the other was the
Merrick Battleship.
Ah, I see.
So those battleships Aquanium power sources might still be
inside them.
It's a possibility.
I have to go to another battleship?
Please!
Ra-ro!
Nobody cares about Aquanium anymore!
He's well aware of the locations of Sandlands Aquanium.
We just want to head to Forest Land.
Far Northeast yet.
But I'd rather be safe and sorry.
Can't you tell General Array and leave things to the Royal
Army?
I could, but it would be quicker to go there ourselves.
And we're stronger anyway.
Maybe you're right.
right their guards were losing weren't they well to be fair
they weren't really guarding while you all go and get the
aquarium i'll stay behind and wrap up our preparations here
so we'll be ready to leave at a moment's notice to be fair
and we're not really doing much of anything what are we
going to do with the aquarium we've already got yeah what
are we gonna do with the aquarium the forest land army might
come after us if we keep it on us you have a point but i
don't know we could ask mayor toy yeah let's hide in the
village that like you know where all the innocent civilians
are that's a good idea because an army would never invade
like would never you know destroy a poor innocent city zion
thank you the super chat thank you thank you i said four
dungeon calls last time and i meant it by the way the 100 mm
EMP gun explosive laser from I'll get it.
Let's put all these innocent civilian lives in danger.
Well, like, except for, like, one.
You know, I won't mind if one of them dies.
Is it just my imagination?
Or has the town gotten more lively?
Yeah, I did my side quest for real this time.
Wait, where's the...
What's that, too?
I was told that their nagein boo is gonna have guns for me
Hey, is it just um, oh wait, where are my guns?
Where are my fucking guns?
I didn't have them unlocked I fucking I have 50 chairs, but
not But not the guns we don't need guns guys No!
I have to do more Sun!
Okay, I am not doing worse.
Oh yeah, we have to upgrade our tanks, right?
We have to upgrade our vehicles.
I mean, uh, okay, we can upgrade this right now.
Uh, we'll go to level 12.
Because we don't have enough Cobra alloys.
Guys, you should tell me...
Guys, why didn't you tell me to farm the Cobra?
Guys, why did you hold my hand to tell me what to do.
Alright, let's see.
We need to customize vehicle.
Alright, there we go.
Okay, we got... I know, like, I have stronger stuff, right?
Need upgraded.
Wait, is this weapon break?
Wait, it can break?
Okay, let's see.
Shots explode on impact.
with a chance by ammo.
Destroyers hard rock.
I guess we should do that because it's upgraded.
It is stronger.
Right?
Yeah.
Okay, everything else is weaker.
So we will not deal with that.
But that means I can.
I should be able to... Oh, wait.
Whoops.
Uh...
Maybe repair the bike?
No.
The bike does.
doesn't need repairs.
It'll be fine.
I believe in the bike.
The bike will be okay, guys.
It'll be okay.
How to upgrade the weapons.
Let me make sure that...
Oh, okay, this one's...
Wait, but...
How is this a blue?
Belt for speed.
Oh!
But then a jump?
What is this?
Boost recovery, boost gauge.
You know what?
Fuck it.
It's blue, so it's better.
Oh, okay.
We need that.
Oh, quick reloads.
My scam bike.
It's this rare.
Reduces energy.
Consume.
Oh, my vehicle's too fucking weak.
Alright, that's fine.
Parts.
Upgrade parts.
Oh, yeah, we can upgrade parts.
Never mind.
We can't.
We don't need to, guys.
Guys, we don't need to upgrade anything, because it's
perfect the way it is.
Let's see.
Okay, cart is useless.
I think that's good.
See you later.
Yeah.
Alright, we gotta talk to the mayor.
Decades.
Marshall, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Decades later, they will discover Aquanium is radioactive
and all of... Oh, no!
Just like uranium.
Just like the plates and the cups.
And like the Garfield cup and the Star Wars cup.
Just because they wanted to make it orange.
Because you broke you into some kind of treasure hunt.
No, sadly.
It's nothing so fun.
This is what I think about like, you know how like Superman
has like x-ray vision.
And like how like some superheroes have x-ray vision.
I'm just thinking.
the potential for like the like whoever he's X-raying like
you know cancer you don't want to know I see it must be
quite the treasure indeed then well you can use the secret
room in the West I'll draw your map we used it to hide our
arms and such during the rebel army days yeah he does
Superman has X-ray vision I'd feel far safer with it there.
I'll go and hide it for you.
You're in a hurry, right?
Leave it with me.
You're gonna be all right on your own?
Aw, look at you, all worried about your knees.
Shut up.
Not.
Knees?
Wait, he...
Wait, really?
Wait, he actually does?
Can somebody cancel?
Okay, now I need to look that up.
Can Superman give someone cancer from X-ray vision?
Okay, now I need to know.
Can Superman give you cancer?
Yes, so could he deliberately give someone cancer just by
looking at them hard enough?
Uh...
Oh, apparently!
Okay.
Superman's vision doesn't work strictly X-rays.
So overall, it seems unlikely that simply looking at you
would...
Okay, unlikely.
Okay, good.
Okay, so no.
His type of x-ray vision.
Oh, wait, guys!
Guys, but look at this.
A patient can have up to 180 plus x-rays a year.
The radiation dosage is small.
It's not a big deal if he looked at someone for a few
seconds.
Guys!
It's okay!
As long as we don't go over 181, we'll be fine.
Like, x-rays.
So, like, in a year, if we really want to, we can go to the
hospital to, like, get, like, 180 x-rays.
And we'll be okay, technically.
Wait, Louis Ling got cancer from Superman?
That can't be real.
Now you're making stuff up.
I feel like that would be a bigger deal.
Oh, no.
She got it by her own.
her own means not by from superman okay yeah that'll be so
fucked up i'll be like that's really up i'll take care of
hiding the stuff see ya why did ann have to go and bring up
the whole niece thing i'll be like that's so messed up is
they actually wrote that into like an official story funny
story one spider-man story mj dies because what that's a
real story don't even chat thank you thank you there was one
spider-man comic where peter killed mj with radioactive
spider okay i'm sorry to let me look that up wait
that's from who the fuck wrote that i need the name okay um
she holy shit what is the sentence that i'm reading Oh my
god Okay, who wrote this that's called spider-man rain Okay,
this is Oh my god, okay, I I did not realize that was real.
Oh my god.
I forgot Spider-Man's like radioactive because he got bit by
radioactive spider.
Like all I thought about was like you know I thought about
like you know like the incredible Hulk and like Superman but
like oh my gosh the hidden the hidden monster all along with
spider rat like wouldn't i mean like every all his like you
know like saliva would be radioactive too like what what if
he like coughs at somebody you know so wouldn't his bacteria
be radioactive like he could technically bring on the second
plague because his radioactive genes the bacteria and like
he could technically start in like the third plague or
something if if okay if like radioactive like goo can give
can cause somebody to die why would you stop there like
everything would just be radioactive at that point okay that
is actually crazy oh my god who is a writer for who came up
with this when was this it was 2007 sorry this was like very
um sorry we diverged a lot but this is actually crazy to
read about that is actually really crazy to read about just
now i was not i was not expecting that okay he also wrote
for it oh he wrote for like Hulk, Iron Fist, Ultimate X-Men,
Hawkeye, and the Amazing Spider-Man.
He included the...
He created the manga-verse Spider-Man?
What?
What the fuck is the manga-verse Spider-Man?
Wait.
Okay.
There's a marble manga-verse?
What?
Why is it called?
Why is it called the manga-verse?
There's a manga verse, by the way.
Is it just regular Spider-Verse?
Yeah, he wrote the manga verse Spider-Man.
But isn't that just a regular, like, multiverse?
The Spider-Man multiverse?
Why does, like, the multiverse have to have a separate
multiverse called the manga verse?
Alright.
Jesus Christ.
But, yeah, this guy.
care andrews he wrote that imagine being in the writer's
room for that snooze thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you spider-man has some bangers like the time sad man
jumped down his throat what okay is there okay he's aquanium
recovery our plan is to head to the merrick battleship in
search of more aquanium
All right, so it's all up to me.
Why do I have to do everything?
What's the point of having an army?
There were so many people in that one army.
All right, we gotta go to the...
Oh, I know about the zombie verse.
I just...
I was...
I...
I'm still blown away from that one.
comic storyline that's insane like peter parker's never
gonna like like he's he's never gonna bang again like after
that like that man is fucking traumatized after that
wait you could like okay is this really fucked up for me to
say but it gives so many like different storylines.
It gives, like, so many different storylines.
Because, like, technically you could, like, study the
radioactive property.
I don't know.
You can use it to find a cure for cancer at that point.
Right?
Like, if you think about it.
Joki, stop cooking.
Okay.
All I'm saying is that you can find the cure for cancer.
Clear thinking will lead you to victory, even when the odds
are against you.
How do I get there?
I'm so confused.
Oh, it's here.
I got lost.
You're talking to the fiend prince.
I'm like the definition of calm.
Yay!
Alright, time to find some Aquanium.
What's that?
Oh, that's a merchant.
Wait, do you have stuff for me?
You have an exclamation point.
You have anything for me?
Can you please?
Hello?
Why did you walk away?
Oh, it's just new stuff.
Okay, I don't need any of this.
See, I told you guys the cutscene heals my bike.
I knew I didn't need to repair my bike.
is marvel's version of the puppy that they love to kick he's
the only one who gets fucked with hard in the series thank
you the super chat pug thank you thank you you are harmless
though just doing their best to survive in this harsh land
like us that's surprising because i feel like everybody has
like all superheroes have trauma how far is this place i
still have to ride it wait there's like stuff wait is this a
town
Oh, it is.
There are other towns?
Terijino.
Where are you?
Can I steal your citizens?
I can't believe... Guys, there's another town!
Why?
Why did nobody tell me about the secret town?
Is this where the mayor is?
Alright, let's see.
Okay, some of us need to stop cooking Jay Thank you for the
super chat Thank you, thank you I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
read D-track Thank you for the super chat Thank you Fun
fact, there's a marble villain That could cure cancer His
name is Soran On all he wants to do is Oh yeah, I remember
that Wait, that's one of my favorite One of my favorite
comic panels I don't know I saw this.
Sorry, I know we're playing Sandland, but I know that comic
panel.
It's one of my favorites.
Because he's, like, apparently really smart.
And then Peter, I think it was Peter, and he was like, why
don't you use your powers to cure cancer?
And he's just like, because dinosaurs are cool.
I love that panel so much.
It's so fucking dumb.
It's like, I don't want to cure cancer i want to turn people
into dinosaur there you guys here here's the panel is
actually it you know what i can like actually show this on
stream it's actually one of my favorite dumb panels of all
time comics just go fucking crazy for no reason here wait oh
my gosh i'm doing something and more important right now.
Can't we just pick them off one by one?
All right, here.
There are only a few, sure.
But with large groups, you risk getting surrounded.
This man know what he wants.
The DNA we liberated from the grave desecration, you call a
museum.
I have perfected the sterilization process.
You rice paper puppets will be giving forest benefiting
herbs dominant species.
You can rewrite DNA on the fly And you're using it to turn
people into dinosaurs But with tech like that You could cure
cancer But I don't want to cure cancer I want to turn people
into dinosaur
This is literally one of my favorite comic pals Because it's
so fucking stupid He knows what he wants
this this this dinosaur knows what he wants all right time
to actually play the game again sorry we've really needed
fucking make it to uh forest land guys i can't i don't know
if i can do another day being in sandland let this man cook
being a dinosaur is just cool there guys you just don't
understand
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Peter recently lost MJ to a child of one of his villains
named Paul.
Buried one of his villains alive.
Put a black suit back on and became the green goblin for
three issue and lost to MJ in a fight.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Comic goes fucking weird sometimes.
Because they always have to... What is that?
Oh, shit!
That's a big toger!
Okay, I might need these hit their materials for, like...
Oh my god.
New animal.
New invasive species.
Technically, they're all invasive species to me because
demons were here first.
Okay, we got a panther bang.
Okay.
There we go.
They're all invasive species.
The demons were here first.
I'm speaking my truth.
Okay, we gotta go this way.
Holy shit, that's a big city!
We're gonna hide our aquarium here.
And create the next attack on Titan scenario.
So this is a human castle, huh?
Stupid big place to live.
And with plenty more people living around it, this has
become an enormous castle town.
Oh my god, there's so many people.
Where do I have to go?
Oh, wait, I didn't start the cutscene?
It'll be you.
Oh my god, that's dumb.
I had to go to that marker.
Okay, how do we get there?
Oh wait, what's this?
Oh, I got somebody's diary.
Hell yeah.
Thoughts are not private anymore.
Heavy galling gun?
Oh my god, guys.
I'm so lost.
Guys, how do I...
Wait, there's a cat.
There's a cat.
Not so Deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, that's fucked up.
That's so fucked up.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
He just wants people to be dinosaurs.
Like, he doesn't care.
He just wants...
wants the world to be dinos we can't pet the cat six out of
ten because not being able to pet animals removes four
points how do i get to the other side jesus christ this is a
huge city that means more taxes oh my god all the taxes
oh my god What the fuck do I?
Am I not supposed to be here?
Like, guys, I don't think I was...
Okay, I don't think I was supposed to be here.
Oh, this is the capital?
I feel like it was supposed to be on the other side.
There's no way.
Yeah.
I thought...
I think this is just a bonus.
I think, like, the...
Oh, no.
No, it is inside.
Wait, what?
What?
Or is it not?
No, it's not.
It's outside.
Alright.
Okay.
Any outsiders going to the capital are required to pass
through a military checkpoint.
Alright.
Where's the military checkpoint?
Now this place is huge.
I didn't know there were more cities.
I thought there were like three.
My city?
That's how they've managed to defend the capital.
The other junkyard city.
See, I told you guys.
They are in immigration.
That's a checkpoint, guys.
That's literally a checkpoint.
I knew there were passports in this world.
Guys, do you think I got my...
Guys, guys, I think I have all my paperwork ready in my
visa.
I think I have my visa to go to Forestland.
Whoops.
That is my visa.
You're a weird one, old man.
Very good.
I got through.
Only death awaits us if we don't help each other.
Is this a bad tank?
That's a bad tank.
Yeah.
That's my visa.
So did the Peachy build this one too?
That they did.
The Peachy's technology never ceases.
But they're so small.
They built all that.
That's actually crazy.
They're able to build all that.
They're like half the size of like a regular person.
Oh my god, that's level 33.
I don't think we can take that on.
I don't think we can run over that cat.
Okay, how do we get there?
I hope this is a new dungeon.
Okay, but how do we get there?
What the fuck is that door?
Oh, whoops.
Ow.
Here we go.
Prince, would you please let me help you?
the next turn at the wheel oh no you don't even have a
driver's license a thief rock paper scissors
i don't know if driving playing rock paper scissors is a
good idea be as a bub there's no way i had a bike we've got
to stay vigilant
This should be it.
Oh, wait.
Where are you going to tell me?
Good.
Oh, good.
Nice.
Wait, that's not it?
Is this just another city?
Holy shit, guys.
It's like it's a country or something.
Oh, my God.
Who would have thought this place is so populated?
Good.
Imagine that.
it's so wild there's actually like different cities a
capital city like there's more to this world than just three
cities what do you mean literally there's a person right in
front of me is there people here i say as i look at it a
human face
another battleship that's all busted up oh this was more the
only way inside is down it's slippery so watch your footing
okay i have to go this way wait do we have to go this way no
yellow i know what to do wait why is there like tricky
jumper oh wait no that's just a bonus mission okay can you
grab our jumper and then we go we all right nice and then
we thank god for yellow paint guys i don't know what i'll do
about it and then we go this way and get off the jumper but
please just let please all i want to do is fucking sad oh
yeah by the way i was curious on like how much more i had of
this game and like to get to my part so like you know okay i
tell you guys like i would try to see gauge how much i have
left of a video game sometimes i feel like well i've been
playing this game for a long time maybe i'm getting closer
to the ending and um so like i went and googled you know
youtube like uh no commentary play through sad land and i i
stopped to the part where i'm supposed to be at where I'm at
from part 3 and I looked at it and then like from them it
literally took that guy like 4 out 4 was it 4 or to 5 hours
to get to the part where I ended last time and like you know
I played like maybe like 16 hours of this game already
maybe okay maybe not 16 maybe like 12 hours of this game if
i'm like and and it took the yeah it took the guy with the
silent like no commentary uh no commentary play through it
took him like four to five hours to get to where i was And I
was like, okay, how much more left of the game for him?
And then I looked at it to see, like, all right, how long
till it takes to the ending.
And I looked at it.
And it was like, oh, I don't know.
It was like maybe like 10 to 12 hours left of the game of
the video.
So I'm just like, oh, if it's our set.
12 hours left from the video for him oh this is gonna i
don't know how long we're gonna be stuck here this might be
like my longest playthrough yet i'm not gonna lie holy we're
we're stuck in Sandland in forever.
Just like a couple more years of Sandland.
But I'm having fun.
I've been enjoying the story so far.
This is why...
But yeah, this is like the rare moment where I play RPGs.
But I should expect that because it is an RPG.
An RPG does like, you know...
known to take a long time but yeah this is why this is like
my first venture into a jrpg game too i go this way door
open marshal thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you yeah but this guy have the 50 his 50 chairs in a room i
think not true marshal true the floor looks fragile yeah
this is supposed to be a short rpg too Crash through on
landing.
Okay, wait.
How do I...
Oh, it's X.
Okay, I was going to say.
How do I collapse this?
I already forgot how.
Is there extra loot here?
No.
Okay.
Wait, but there's an extra hole here.
Or there's an extra hole.
There's loot.
Where's the...
Oh, there it is.
Okay, give me that loot.
Nice.
I love loot.
wait I need to kill you for loot too get over here get over
again I need your claws I need to upgrade my my bots let's
see all right we go this way that's a dead boy thank you for
the super chat thing thank you hour of gameplay to two hours
of yapping checks out to the doki stream experience wouldn't
have it any other way thank you for the super chat thank
Thank you.
I'm happy to the people who have stuck it out to, like, the
four parts already.
Because, like, this is also why I tend to avoid, like,
longer games.
Because I know, like, you know, the longer the game series,
the less people will watch it.
Just because, you know, people are like, ooh, it's a lot of
time investment to it.
So I really appreciate the dragoons that have, like, uh,
stuck stuck out.
Because we have a long way to go.
We're not even at last.
I was like, hey, Gerard.
Oh, yeah, yeah, this game for Akira.
It's actually been pretty enjoyable so far.
But it is a GRPG though, so it's a long series.
These things are huge.
The Aquanium should be on the top floor.
Let's start climbing.
Get out of here.
Oh my god, wait, this is just an innocent bystander.
Oh well.
There's no innocent bystander in the land of this is a
lawless land what's yours is mine
hey guys I'm just gonna walk past you guys oh wait except
for you, you have a bazooka oh hey loot alright, where do I
go?
do I go this way?
oh I go this way
rated out of 10?
I think the story I don't really normally play JRPG but this
is like it oh, that guy's definitely dead I don't give it
like 7 or an 8 I don't normally play JRPGs But like I've
been enjoying this JRPG There are some dungeons That could
are a bit repetitive though Let's see And you can drive a
tank See Boom I have a tank
Alright which way do I go Wait where's the Oh my god if we
didn't have rio please just close your hatch it's literally
the door it's literally that fucking door i think that's why
i can't go through
all right we gotta use the jump butt
all right also it also if you're directionally challenged
you get the yellow boxes which is great because i'm very
directionally challenged you're all right so i very the
yellow the yellow paint all right goodbye guys like you
don't have to commit murder but if you want to you can like
this oh wait there's loot I gotta commit a murder there's
free loot
uh Rooze thank you for the super chat thank you thank you I
avoid JRPG streams like a plague but for Doki I will always
show up thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
Thank you for showing up.
I really appreciate it.
And I know, like, JRPG is not, like, a thing for everybody.
Especially, like, since I'm known more so for, like, you
know, FPS games and not JRPG.
Oh, my God!
They jumped away.
That's illegal.
Okay, get out of here.
Get out of here.
All right.
Let's see.
this way.
There has to be loot here because it's not part of the map.
The yellow paint didn't tell me to go this way.
So there has to be loot.
Thin's the rules.
Wait, yellow paint!
Yellow paint!
There's so much yellow paint!
But where does it lead?
Where does the yellow paint lead?
Okay.
Woo!
all right wait how do i fuck do i where am i going this
better be like some insane loot it's like where am i okay
can i can i destroy this with this no i have to use a tank
nope oh no okay oh no oh wait it works nice all right this
works so i'll destroy that wait no I had to be up top.
Boop.
Alright.
Oh, yes.
Loot.
Yay!
I get to upgrade my tank.
Then we got this out of the way.
Wait, how do I get across from here?
What?
It's from there?
Oh, no.
I have to use my brain.
Can't believe it.
The yellow paint isn't holding my hand.
anymore where does this do oh wait no i can jump from here
no no wait maybe from here no that's where i came from oh it
lets me like go back that's what it was for was that it is
that all the loot wait that has to be Alright, I got my
loot.
Now off I go.
Me, the bike is faster.
Yay!
Goodbye.
Is this way?
Yes, this way.
Please.
No.
Oh my god, it's like parallel parking.
I felt like I was parallel parking just then.
Okay.
Yay, we made it.
Okay, I get the jump bot.
Not a good place to call it?
Is it because I was because I was too close to the square?
Alright, off we go.
Back to the objective.
Down we go.
And...
This way.
The driver's license.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
It's time to kill the other jump bots.
All right, no, this is too baby.
I gotta bring in the big boys.
Sorry, I forgot to reload.
That is an issue that has never left me.
That's right.
I'm bringing the big guns.
You think you can jump away from your problems?
I can run you over.
I have a tank.
Oh, shit.
Baby.
Okay.
Level 13, please.
Who let this child into this fight?
Alright, I think that's everybody.
We can get to the next floor from here.
I can't wait to get to Forestland because I'm really sad
that this dungeon is basically like the...
You know the last dungeon we had where we're in the
battleship?
We're back in the...
It's just the same battleship, but there's more sand.
please why you gotta do this to me why did you bring me back
to the to the this fucking dungeon okay loot time okay i
mean it's another battle it's literally the same battleship
it's made by the same general of that battleship oh my gosh
i keep you know what i'm gonna Ryo.
Do it.
Do the thing.
Shoot him.
Shoot him, Ryo.
Ryo, please shoot your gun.
Shoot your gun one time.
That's all I ask, Ryo.
Shoot it.
Oh my god, I swear to God.
I...
I swear to fucking God, right?
It took him 80 years and thousands.
That was the damage he did.
Yeah, the only issue, I think the only reason why, I feel
like this game definitely deserves a bit more popularity.
But like, it was just very unfortunate that it was released
around the same time as Stellar Blade.
Because all the streamers were playing Stellar Blade instead
of this.
I feel like, I feel like if like they didn't overlap, if
they didn't overlap with Stellar Blade release, I feel like
this game would have been more popular.
Because it is, it is entertaining.
It's interesting.
I do like it.
Yay!
Yeah, and everybody wanted to play waifu Dark Souls.
Which I don't blame them.
I mean, it's literally waifu Dark Souls.
Mistakes, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
RPGs are pretty are pretty doll to watch, but you saying
laughing about Queenium makes it worth it.
I like the story of this game so far.
It's been pretty interesting.
Am I going the right way?
Yeah.
I am.
Oh my god!
I've been recently watching the boys.
No spoiler, but like oh my god.
I I It's the Eric Kripke curse.
I don't know if you guys know who Eric Kripke is.
But, like, he wrote Supernatural.
And, like, if you never watched Supernatural, it was really
good in the beginning.
But the more seasons it gets, the worse it gets.
Because it's like, Eric Kripke, he's...
It's like, what's his name?
It's like that, the creed, oh, what's his name?
Ryan Murphy?
I don't know if you guys know the writer, Ryan Murphy.
But it's similar to, like, Ryan Murphy and, like, his
series.
Like, he wrote, like, Lee, Rip and Nip and Tuck or
something, like, the surgery one.
And, like, so, like, him and Ryan Murphy, they both have,
like, the big weakness where they have a really, really good
premise and beginning seasons.
one or three seasons is like really good and then it's like,
you know, it starts getting not great.
Yeah, I know he left in season five, but even then, like,
the show was starting to get, like, even before season five,
the show was starting to get, like, you know.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, please.
No, it's the self-destruct ones.
um oh no it's 2d time but yeah i checked out the new season
of the boys because then there's a couple i honestly thought
season three of the boys was like pretty rough i wasn't
really a big fan of season three of the boys um because like
i felt like the story please get away from me i'm trying to
talk about the boys oh it does nothing okay a little bit
explosion doesn't hurt me um but like It was, uh, how do I
say?
Like, season three of the boys started fizzling out for me.
This is, because there was, like, a pattern to it, which was
each episode has either sex or gore.
And, like, it was literally, like, it was so much of it.
It was, like, inserted there for no reason.
That was season three for me.
Season, I was, like, season four, I couldn't believe it, but
they inserted more.
like i feel like i watched the first three episodes of
season four of the boys and and like i swear every scene had
to at least have one like freaky sex scene or like one
really particularly gory moment or sex and gore yeah and
like but the thing is it's there for no reason like this
thing there for like no reason.
As I say, season three, it started off okay, but then it
started getting like the plot and everything started getting
weird.
To be fair, the comics are worse.
The comics are not great.
I read the comics of The Boys.
And like, if you guys never, um, if you guys never read the
comics, the boys was written by a writer who just really
hated superheroes.
Like he fucking hated the superhero genre and the comic was
like really bad Like I read and I don't know I don't know so
like maybe somebody actually liked the comics But it was
just it was written they added shock factored for the sake
of shock factor not for the sake of the story
And so like so like I yeah, but then like the thing is like
At least the boys, they had some really, the show had some
funny moments here.
But, like, I swear, I only laughed, like, once for the first
three, the three episodes for season four.
I laughed only, like, one time.
It was just, I don't know, it was just not funny.
The first three episodes, just not funny.
It was just, it was just sex, gore, or both.
I don't know Also like Homelander's kid I swear to God Not a
spoiler thing But they made him a fucking squeaker For no
reason I swear I swear to God I'm pretty sure it doesn't
actually sound like that He's clearly going through puberty
right now But like I swear Okay I'll describe a scene that's
not spoiler But there's a scene in there homelander's kid um
he plays a rip-off video game of like mortal combat like a
parody of mortal combat no but like but like but like okay
so like he he plays a parody of mortal combat and then he
like talks on mic for it and like he he like he exaggerated
hit I swear he like made himself even squeakier I couldn't
it because like you're parodying like squeakers on on like
gaming so like they made him feel like his voice cracks the
entire time and I'm like I swear you used to be able to talk
like what
oh my god it is actually insane like it was just a parody of
squeakers when he was talking in game because like after he
finished playing he didn't sound like that anymore i was
like what the fuck um zonder man thank you the super chat
thank you thank you you're not laughing how could it be not
my oh shit look if you saw the first three episodes of the
boys you would understand
but i hope it changes changes because it's honestly i i i'm
a bit sad that the first three episodes is like really meh
oh my god what are they doing here all right any day now are
you guys gonna make it hey it's you guys let's see what
they're back what are you up to you were eavesdropping
weren't you yeah you were fixing to go and get your hands on
the Aquanium first, weren't you?
Yeah, they're doing the Baywatch.
Well, yeah, but I mean, not anymore.
What are they doing here then?
No one told us it was being guarded by that.
By what?
Talk for a bunch of cowards.
What's that?
Never mind, then.
Let's worry about what's that?
The swimmers.
What is that?
It's lame.
I don't know but yeah I don't know I hope the newer episodes
of the boys because I actually was really looking forward to
it really looking forward to it and like oh my god okay like
there was like there's so many and then they like they
introduced a lot of new characters all of a sudden in the
new season and then like and I'm like who the fuck are these
people season that there was like they've always like they
try to pretend that they've always been there and everything
and i was like wait i don't remember these people more than
they could chew all right time to get the big boys in right
on do your thing oh god wait have we fought i thought wait a
minute why guys what do i do p guys i think i should have
leveled up guys i I think I might have like fucked up by not
leveling up this is gonna take a while
this might take a while
there there is a bots are positively swarming out of the no
oh wait I can just let's take it out if i just don't head
there i'll just stand in the center it's not like they can
hit me right oh my god this is actually gonna take forever i
messed up a little bit okay nice all right okay oh my god
this is gonna take forever guys oh no not you too of the
little turrets.
Ryle, come back!
Ryle, please!
Oh, I'm only halfway!
I'm not leading my shots anymore.
Oh, this sucks.
The sticky one sucks.
Okay.
All right, here we go.
You need to get rid of these guys.
It's fine.
I have so many repair kits because I don't heal.
Oh, no.
Oh, that's not fine.
It's okay if I stand here, he can't get me.
I'll just stand here.
It's okay.
If I stand here, he can't get me.
We're halfway through.
We're almost there.
Okay.
Wait, electric?
Oh!
Guys, I can't!
It's...
No!
durability.
I'm trying!
This is not fair!
My tank can't jump!
That's not fair!
My tank can!
Oh, guys, guys, guys, guys!
Guys, okay.
Where's the heal?
Oh, thank God.
Okay, repair kit.
Yay!
Oh, we need firepower.
Okay, guys, we're gonna use everything.
All right.
There we go.
There we go, guys.
See, nothing bad is gonna happen to me.
See, look at that!
And I boost up the firepower.
Okay, nice.
I should have done that in the beginning.
I have so many power-ups.
The tank can't jump, guys!
What do you mean, jump?
This tank wasn't made to jump!
Oh!
Oh, God.
This is bad.
Oh, this is bad.
Okay, we have another Repair Kit.
And then we'll use another one.
And then we're going to use another defense.
We're so close.
It's so close.
Okay, nice.
Oh, don't worry.
I can take this.
Come on.
He's there two hits.
No, I'm missing.
I'm missing.
He's literally in front of me.
Okay, there you go.
At least that was sort of fun.
Easy.
It's so easy.
It only took all my upgrades that I've stocked up until now.
Wow.
Just what I'd expect from the fiend prince.
Yeah.
I thought you ran off.
My gut told me to come back and guard the aquarium from bad.
No, not you.
Not you too.
You just wanted to grab it for yourself.
You think we're just gonna let that slide?
No.
listen it's true I do want to protect it well we were
planning on selling it to that armed group at first selling
it should it they don't need to know that I mean I knew it'd
fetch a fine price if I sold it we need the money for you
can finally swim when I realized someone could use it for
something as awful as that disaster 30 years ago.
I have a few contacts in the Forest Land Resistance.
Hmm.
He seems to be...
You don't need to be like rebels anymore.
I am.
You can literally swim now.
So do you want us gain entry to Forest Land?
That I can't do.
Joining forces with you would be collaborating with the
Royal Army.
Yeah, what's wrong with that?
I'd never be able to face my friends in the Rebel Army
that's understandable if it's any consolation you can have
this it's the core frame for a hoverbot are you sure papa
hoverbot to all that trouble to find it we're the swimmers
we don't need a bot for crossing water oh I have a robot for
water wait I'm trying to what the fuck is this game's
writing i'm using a a water bot to like go to forest land
illegally now then let's get to searching for that aquarium
like who wrote all right let's level up man what i love oh i
need two okay i don't have enough yet uh pow pow or creature
with your Pow, pow, what the fuck is, pow, pow?
Timmer increased the attack of, oh, wait, I like that.
Increases the attack of my, of my thing.
Ginger, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I wonder if I can rock the swimmer's outfit.
Do it, do it at a convention.
All right, goodbye, I don't need you guys.
I don't need you guys.
Here we go.
I gotta make my new bot.
Wait, is this Aquanium?
Knock knock.
Aquanium!
Drop it.
Let a child.
Yeah, let a child hold on to it.
Now we found all of the Aquanium in Sandland.
All two of them.
It looks like we're gonna have to make it past.
the border first and would know how to do it she snuck
across the border before after all guys come on let's just
get passports and visas guys let's get back to spino
all right we gotta go back wait can i just oh i have to get
out from here guys we literally have connection to the king
we don't have to illegally go to forest land guys we have
connections with the king now how do i get out of here oh
this way right here guys i can't believe it guys oh my god
finally guys we're gonna make it to forest lad i told you i
told you it's not clickbait we're finally gonna make it oh i
forgot to i forgot to skip the cutscene for that This is it.
We're gonna see what it looks like.
Yay.
How do I get there faster?
This way?
Which way is the exit?
Oh, this way.
I feel like I missed the shortcut.
Unless it wants me to go the long way.
Oh, wait, what?
This way?
I'm sorry.
surprised that oh i guess we make our own shortcut we make
our own shortcut we don't need them to tell us where to go i
say as i follow the checkpoint i don't get out of here i
don't get out of here yeah this is where we started but how
the fuck do i get out oh hey loot loot time okay this way so
here oh this way okay it was like the checkpoints were like
overlapping each no okay okay god alright I thought I fucked
up okay nice nice and then big jump and then big jump guys
how the fuck I messed up that's this way Oh my god Why am I
trying to make my own pathway When I can just follow the
yellow brick road Okay I keep forgetting there's a yellow
brick road Painted just for me Yeah Right up I go Got the
jump bot It's a lot faster now too Right gotta get off the
jump butt it was loot that's fine that's not important it's
fine it can't be that important guys we're just a little
under level that's okay
oh wait what no what in the Who would have thought when I
said we shouldn't hide an aquarium in the in the tiny city?
I can't believe it.
What I said was going to happen actually happened.
Forestland Army.
Damn.
You think the town's okay?
Who could have predicted this?
Is my chairs okay?
Guys, I need to know.
What up My chairs
What up Guys I spent two hours Getting the sound The cat
threw this at me My two hours
Alright See I mean they're okay What the fuck Why did the
outside look so dangerous But everybody's okay There's no
fire inside Oh Where's the fire?
Mayor Tor, what happened here?
Yeah, what happened?
I have no clue.
What?
This forest land army showed up out of nowhere, demanding an
quenium.
When I said we had none, they started firing.
Who brought him here?
The guy with the scar?
Half stash?
No.
Their commander was a woman.
Cold as ice.
Absolutely merciless.
You held out well against them.
Rebel army experience, I guess.
It's not that.
It was Anne who saved our town.
What did Anne do?
Anne did.
Yeah, they couldn't get past the wall.
She surrendered, saying she'd lead them to the Aquanium.
When was this?
Why is it all the old people saying Aquanium?
Old man, you remember that map of the secret room in the
West?
There's a secret room?
Yeah.
I don't remember.
All right.
In addition, In addition to Epi and Kroa, there's this other
third commander.
Who would have thought?
It's like the army has like multiple, like leaders in power.
It's not crazy, guys.
There's more than two.
Fighting fire with fire, eh?
I hate to admit it, but it makes sense.
No way.
Don't worry, Enko Bell is going to save the day.
Wait, does that mean you're going to fix my...
better at hotter at finally all right we can upgrade oh we
can upgrade a lot actually they want to go all the way low
15 uh i used all the croc steel again because i forgot about
you oops i forgot that you also need to upgrade it's all
right you didn't need the upgrade oh my Oh, yeah, I used all
that up as well.
Okay, oops.
Whoops.
That's awkward.
All right, let's see if there's any new parts.
Battle tank, battery fires two shots at once.
Okay.
The mag is stronger, but the damage is lower, so I don't
think I'm going to use.
Yeah, I don't think any of them is better.
Well, balance.
Okay, I like the speed more.
Oh, yeah, I don't think there's anything new.
Hope to see you soon.
Alright, here we go.
We gotta go find Anne.
We gotta get Gadget back for my Chippendale army.
This way?
Alright.
This way.
Buy health potions?
I don't need health potions.
I'm strong enough.
What do you hear?
What are your special ears?
Holy shit, their tanks are...
Their tanks look stronger.
Oh, sorry.
Oh my god.
Her assets.
Deception ill befits a princess.
Cease the stubbornness for your own good.
Oh, what the fuck?
So you recognize me.
Even though it's been 10 years.
That's her eyes are up there.
Of course.
You may look older.
But what's inside has not changed.
Yeah, why are your things cooler?
The way you smile, how you talk, your endless naivete.
But you have changed, Rosetta.
You used to be so kind.
Are they like childhood friends?
No, roommates.
I would say you're the odd one for remaining so static.
In any case, that's enough pointless chit-chat.
We have an Aquanium radar back in Forest Land.
Just a couple of our gals being pals.
There is no point in continuing this charade.
we'll just see about that the girl escaped save her oh my
god she just I don't think that's called escaping she's oh
my god she ran one way she's escaping like what the fuck
that's not escaping she just ran away pull yourselves
together remember generally jogs demons are no match for the
illustrious rosetta brigade holy shit their tanks are so oh
my god these tanks are serious they have no eyes you know
they're serious when they're tanks have no eyes and then you
pan over to my fucking junkyard of a 10 guys oh guys oh wait
their tanks are so weak oh budget cuts budget cuts some
tanks have you know not all tanks can be winners never mind
my tanks are my tanks better these guys clearly like had
some budget cuts like what the fuck why is your tanks so
weak Did you make your take out of plastic?
Mass produced, yeah.
Never mind.
They might look cool, but they were clearly mass produced.
You can buy them on Team Move.
The power of stats.
Ha!
Too easy.
We won't give in.
For the honor and glory of our general.
at it again stop right there it's one of those tanks you can
get for free but you just have to pay for shipping sorry oh
my god a gun shooter she's half demon take the risk i was
unsure the bullet will bounce off right she must have got
the better half right of the demon part everything you've
heard about demons is untrue You truly haven't changed.
Dropship tanks.
It's the same bleeding heart you used to be.
And you, Rosetta.
I don't even recognize you.
You freaks know where these friends...
Bro!
This is very xenophobic.
Good.
Bring it to me or else.
Whoa!
I'm gonna write You don't want me to write a twit longer and
cancel you
Yeah, you can't say that word anymore
I would forgive her I would forgive her look Just because...
Wait, where's the gun?
Why are they just standing there like that?
Hello?
Stop right there.
Oh.
Where is the Aquanium?
Why are they just standing like that?
I'm like, they just...
Man standing emoji.
Sorry, woman standing emoji.
I'm just like, why are they just standing there?
What the fuck?
can't call right i have to use my goddamn legs i can't
believe it i have to use my legs guys what you trying to say
we can't give this up just to save some girl oh it's this
way i would never we can't leave we just put it here in the
hands of her enemies wow this hole is like not very secret
this is literally the first hole
guys this hole is not very secure it's literally the first
hole you find also got the one from the merrick battleship
and what they don't know they won't get yeah i see serves
them right how do you figure out that there's a hole there
there's so many holes in this cave caves are filled with
holes have it here then throw it to me The whole issue
regarding Aquanium is that we can't drop it That is actually
fucking crazy that she was like throw the Aquanium I made no
such promise What but we gave you the Aquanium just thrown
the girl first did I say I'd release her in exchange Oh my
gosh.
She got me there.
She's so smart as if I would ever negotiate with demons.
Then what are you gonna do with her?
Can't say that anymore.
Like I would tell you, demon.
Oh my god, she's so...
My experience with General Rosetta 164.
My 1,800...
My like 50 page document.
google docs don't move follow me and the princess will pay
none of you are to move a muscle until we are fully out of
sight how would they know she's not even looking back damn i
thought i busted up every last one of their tanks looks like
some of them just pretended to be out of commission they
exploded what do you mean pretended to be out of
Solid attacks explode!
How can you pretend?
Yeah, what about just fast travel?
You know how you feel Prince, but get a hold of yourself.
We still have a chance to get Anne back.
He can pretend to explode.
We know where to find more Aquanium that we can use as a
bargaining chip.
Bargaining, smargany.
I literally only have one Aquanium.
What do you mean?
I only have like one more.
That's a spirit.
This land has two Aquaniums.
I can't just find more.
That's probably Aure.
We'll rendezvous at Spino and discuss our next move.
Can I go to Forest Land yet?
We must be able to go to Forest Land, right, guys?
Is it time?
Okay, my two whole Aquaniums.
Alright, what do you have for me, General?
there you are you don't look so good anyone can tell you've
barely slept for weeks it's been weeks i swear i thought
this whole thing happened in like three days wait wait how
can what how can it be weeks already i thought it's been
like two to three days you don't look so chipper yourself a
lot's happened All right, I saw you like two hours ago.
What?
They took Anne?
And the Aquanium too?
This forest land even real?
I'm not going to hurt Anne, right?
I can't say for sure.
We'll have to go to Forest Land after them.
Would you be able to help us get across the border?
It's been following real time.
I left the game two weeks ago, and it's been following that
since.
There's currently a powder keg.
There's only a small sliver of land beyond the big, damn
where our territory and forest lands meet in the first place
and with our armies at a standoff not even a scorpion could
slip through let us adam we'll just force our way through if
you attack at the flashpoint it'll look bad like we've
allied with the demons to attack forest land then we really
would are there actually no demons in forest land i think
that horse has left the stable except for like my sister
that's kind of a tricky subject you know our forces aren't
organized we can't risk all-out war yet so we can't go to
forestland is that what you're saying no they can't do this
to me i i swear i wouldn't clickbait this time have you ever
heard of the cardamo subterranean lake ruins i don't know
maybe i killed all of them oh my god they're serious about
about being xenophobic problem is that it wasn't a joke now
that the river's I don't know whether you can make your way
through.
At the very least, you're going to need some sort of boat.
In that case, we've got the perfect ride.
The hoverbot!
Oh yeah, the hoverbot!
Without Anne and Blueprints, we can't assemble the bot.
Well, in that case, allow me to lend a hand.
Finally!
I still have the plans from when I was helping Anne.
Plans for a hoverbot?
awfully convenient it's designed for crossing over quicksand
but it'll work really well the peachy know their bots yeah
wouldn't the peachy be better than and because the peachy
like did more technology stuff that we do so why did we let
an upgrade our stuff we should have had pete like we should
have polak done all our upgrades away from the ruins
appreciate it nice job better and
oh my god what would you like to do do we have to like you
know go back to save it i mean we already have a replacement
all right we need to create how do we create vehicles again
make vehicle oh there you go uh hover no wait what how
primary weapon secondary weapon engine suspension okay parts
make parts all right we need to make hover oh we have
everything there's a dirt buggy we have another car wait
wait a minute when did this car show up i didn't even notice
the other car all right well we don't need that we literally
have a motorbike so like we don't need that anyway quality
gun powder rocket launcher dual super okay i'm too lazy to
we're not farming materials man we're not getting any of
that okay here we go and then we're gonna get that
yeah uh vehicle make vehicle Cover car.
Okay, we have this.
Oh.
Okay, and then equipment.
There you go.
That should be it, right?
Did I make it?
Oh, wait, I didn't make it.
Oops.
Okay.
I don't have crocs yet.
No!
I need B green.
Okay, where the fuck is that merchant?
We need crocs.
Rocksteel and B-grade, uh, okay.
You should have it, right?
You should have it, Vest, right?
B-grade, was it B-grade steel?
No, I don't have the money.
I need...
What the fuck is a desert crocodile?
Oh, what's a desert crocodile?
I don't...
Have I seen a desert crocodile?
What?
Thank you!
Have I ever seen one?
I don't even remember.
Okay, like one time.
Okay, that does not sound great.
Alright, let's see.
Can I decrease the level of the car?
No.
No!
What is going to be level 12?
.
Why is it at...
Why, Pollock, I don't want to be Mr. Fancy Pens!
Oh, my gosh.
Alright, we gotta figure out where...
Now!
Near Quick Stand.
Guys, where was Quick Stand again?
Is this Quick Stand?
Sand Cascade.
East Valley.
Guys, where... What is Quick Stand?
Giant Raptor Cave Mind Shaft Paternal Nest Junk Pit What was
Quicksand?
Self Self somewhere.
Thank you.
It's just self somewhere.
What the fuck is a...
Where the fuck does Quicksand look like?
What does it look like?
it may be it okay maybe there's one here okay those are
scorpions this quicksand I mean there's so many sand how do
I know which one is what is which one's quick I guess we'll
go down it looks like sand but how do we know it's quick hey
old man what would you do if you ran into a enemy let's see
kill it well i'd start by observing them carefully is that
quick knowing what they can do and what their weaknesses are
will help you fight effectively the one that goes quicker
bro why doesn't it tell you what quicksand looks like like i
mean like what doesn't tell you where
just show me where it is that looks like quicksand it's a oh
there is crocodiles oh my god this is it this is the first
time i saw a crocodile this is it there's a cave or
something under the quicksand there's a quick cave sorry the
aquarium messed me up a little bit no no please get me up oh
i need get the bike out no get closer crocodile crocodile
get closer i need your lord get closer crocodile okay there
you go leave them i need i need to get there okay nice all
right they might have survived mill millennia wait that's a
huge wait oh it's fine don't worry that's why i have no
that's not what i mean oh oh hey they're just oh shit okay i
was gonna say that's why i have rival it's okay push him
into the cave keep clear and attack from a distance okay
nice i'll just stay here that's what rival is for all right
what the are they doing bro Move along.
This is not your fight.
What are you doing here?
The random raptor that just came in.
He's just like, hey, I want to have fun too.
Let me in.
Let me add him.
Okay, nice.
I killed husband and wife.
Yeah!
More crocodile steel.
Thank God.
Alright, let's go in.
I might as well, I'm here anyway.
We might as well.
Might as well grab some extra loot too.
Okay.
Alright.
Yay!
They survived millennia of evolution.
They outlived the dinosaurs just for me to come in here with
my tank.
That's good.
Oh, we need the cobra.
We need that for upgrades, too.
If they didn't want to die to a tank, they should have been
extinct.
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
What's he going to do?
Fight my tank?
Knowing what they can do and what the weaknesses are will
help you fight effectively.
Oh, no.
I'm sorry.
I did not meet it.
No, my tank!
My tank is stuck in the hole!
No!
Yeah, they shouldn't have evolved.
Yeah, they should have evolved.
You're right.
The crocodile should have evolved to be anti-tank.
Whoa.
How did I do that?
If they didn't want to die, they should have evolved better.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
There's more?
Wait, I can't...
What?
my tank's not strong enough there's no way my tank is too
baby all right it's fine we'll just kill the scorpions all
right let's mine this area oh it's a crawl space oh I
couldn't tell what goes through your head in the middle of a
fight nothing I'm gonna beat the other guy to a pulp That's
a start, but you might couldn't see a hole in there It was
oh, there it is I see the hole Give me a sec, scorpion Give
me a sec Oh my god, that's fucked up I'm still crawling Not
Guys, even though I killed your entire family It does not
give you the right to Spit acid on me What the fuck is that
Oh What is that?
What did I do?
Yeah, I got spawn camps.
Oh, no.
No!
Okay, let me...
Alright, and then I'll get off the bike.
It blocked the hole.
Alright, Apako.
Give me the loot!
You should keep our distance from the army base unless
necessary.
Wait, I'm outside?
I bet they've got loads of loot in there.
What?
where am i what
there's I thought there was more that's it that was it it
just took me here I'm back in the sand okay now oh god I
have to get out of here here we go guys I'll get to forest
land I swear to god guys we just had some little
intermissions, some technical difficulties in the sand.
Alright, now I should be able to travel.
No, there's still enemies?
Somehow I doubt they'd take kindly to intrude.
Stop!
Alright, that guy's gonna die.
I don't care about him.
Can you make sure I fly away from everybody?
Okay, now I should be able to fast travel.
God damn it!
Why is there so many wildlife?
Why?
Now I should be able to travel.
Alright.
It's not a myth.
It's real.
Anne came from Forestland.
Chad.
She came from Forestland.
It has to be real.
Okay.
We need to buy the...
What was it called?
Was it bolt or steel?
Chad.
I don't remember.
Maybe it was bolt or steel.
Because we have a lot of iron ore anyway.
What was Anne?
She's my niece.
Apparently.
Was it steel or was it its bulk?
Alright.
Like 20?
Okay, we'll buy 20.
I don't remember how many I need, so I'll just buy 20.
Alright.
Croc steel.
Oh yeah, Croc steel.
We need it.
I'll buy 5 because I don't remember how many we need.
Thank you!
Alright, nice.
One day you'll be just as good as your brother, Bob.
What was...
We can finally make our goddamn car.
Okay, and...
Boop, boop, boop.
Okay, nice.
We're not money?
No, I should have.
Why am I missing?
Why can't I...
Why won't it let me upgrade?
I don't...
I don't understand.
Let me make the car.
What am I missing?
I...
Guys, I did not realize there was a scroll bar.
Okay, I need scorpion.
Alright, scorpion alloy.
Where the fuck?
How do I make scorpion alloy?
And why can't you make...
why can't only make oil thank you why are you not good as
good as your brother what how do i how do i make scorpion
allies go to the trader post i have a traders post the
fuck's the traders post who's the trader don't i have like a
permanent Oh, here...
Are you a traitor?
No.
You're not a traitor.
Thank you for coming.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
I should have.
I should have picked...
Oh, oh, she...
He gave me a scorpion alloy.
Oh, thank god.
I got a freebie.
Thank you.
Thank you, Nya Jinboo.
For the freebie.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, now we can make it.
All right.
Okay, what do we call you?
We're gonna call you a mistake.
All right.
There you go.
Yay!
I've done it.
I finished the hoverbot.
You did it, Polak!
Forest land, here we come!
what do we do about the aquarium should we stash it
somewhere let's put it back here again we didn't learn our
lesson no we better keep it with us they said they've got an
aquarium radar back in forest land if that's true trying to
hide the aquarium is gonna be pointless so that's how they
always seem to know exactly where to find it but wait if
that's true Why couldn't they do it earlier then?
We'll expose our own location.
Well, you're right, Ralph.
Would you mind showing me that Aquanium for a second,
please?
Sure.
Their radar is probably just a receiver.
We want to tune specifically to the wavelength of Aquanium.
Versus sending out radio pulses that bounce off the Aquanium
and back to them.
You're so smart, Pola.
Which means...
all we have to do is wait better and is literally better in
every way why wasn't she doing upgrades on my tanks i see
she literally figured that out in like 10 seconds you mean
you understand how it works of course not but whatever they
just did means that radar can't find it now right she should
have been my main mechanic well that takes care of my
concerns Time to go.
Yeah, just you wait, Forest Land Army.
Anne could have done that.
Anne could have literally covered up the aquarium in the
beginning.
What exactly did they need Anne to show them the way if they
had radar?
Wait, that's true.
Probably because they can't call back home while they're in
Sandland.
Oh.
This gap in their communication network is one of the few
advantages.
Don't have enough walkie-talkies.
all right let's hang out with with better and for a little
bit i'm gonna use the bathroom chat i'll be back first
bathroom break i'll be back guys hey
guys i'm back all right time to finally use my mistake uh we
gotta go wait where do we okay wait request over there no
we're not talking to that lady in the furniture shop we
don't know her Guess we never talk to the lady in the
furniture shop.
Okay The lady at the furniture shop is off limits Where do
you have to go?
Oh this way Is there like a closer spot There closer spot
there Yeah, she is a no-go guys We should just have to keep
going south past the southwestern church Please, I never
expected Forest Land to be so far.
Who would have thought?
Ow.
Why is Forest Land so far?
Who's this guy?
Wait, that's a child.
What is this child doing here?
If enemies take you by surprise, just stay calm and try to
get distance from where's your parents who is it did you
bring me flowers again who are you no because above those
are supposed to be our inside thoughts
that's our inside thoughts be as above can't you see i'm a
fiend oh sorry i'm i'm blind oh shit You bullied a blind
person!
Bees above!
Should you be outside on your own?
That's fucked up.
I just had to thank the flower person.
It's okay.
He's already in hell.
He's already a demon.
Yeah, who is he?
They always leave flowers for me when I'm not paying
attention.
Okay.
This makes...
Okay, that's a little...
That's a little uncomfortable little girl.
Why would they do...
Yeah, why did they do that?
I don't know.
That's why I want to ask them.
I hear me eat lunch and dinner right now.
But I guess I can't.
Since I can't be outside all the time.
If they come in secret, they'd likely stay away if they saw
you.
Oh my god.
I just wanted to thank them for all those fragrant flowers.
Do you have any idea as to who it might be?
Is it your parents?
Sometimes I feel like I can smell a hint of flowers drifting
in from the north.
I see.
So this flower person approaches from the north.
What are you people doing?
What do you want with my lasso?
You'd best not be up to anything.
Grandma, we are not the people you should be worried about.
You should be worried about the flower person.
Ma'am, I assure you, we didn't do anything.
Stop, Grandma.
They're not bad people.
Wait, how do you...
How could a demon not be bad?
Grandma, we're not the one you should be worried about.
I hate humans.
Let's teach you a lesson, Prince.
What for?
She knows her stuff.
Demons are evil, all right?
Damn.
You plan on looking for that flower person, right?
She sounds like somebody that used to live in Forestland.
If you insist.
Let's find that goody two shoes.
Find the troop behind the mysterious Fyler person.
No.
I'm just gonna head to Forestland.
Okay, not...
Okay, now I'm gonna head over.
No!
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, I'm gonna grab the...
Wait, this time.
I got the momentum.
Yay!
I told you guys.
Am I going the right way?
Oh no.
No, no, no, no!
Okay.
Okay, guys, this time.
This time.
Yeah!
There you go.
God fucking...
Okay.
All right.
After all that HP, you're right.
Maybe it doesn't work.
Guys, Mipi Raoul is right And it doesn't work, guys I just
want to do it faster But I didn't realize it wasn't that
fast Wait, I have the hover bot What the fuck am I doing?
Hover Toggle hover Move Shoot, okay What am I doing?
I literally have a car for this.
I'm just like, wait a minute.
I literally have a car.
Crafts, agriculture, hunting, trade.
It's pretty varied.
And some bad eggs resort to thievery, of course.
We steal from humans sometimes, too.
Yeah.
That's nothing to be proud of.
Unless you're stealing from the army, that is.
way?
I don't know.
I'm just going to head this way.
But how do I get back up top, though?
Is that another city?
Yeah, it is pretty slow.
I don't know if I'm going the right way.
I have to be going the right way, though, right?
I'm just, like, wondering, like, how do I get back up top?
Oh, my God.
It's so slow.
Wait, if I go here...
No, I think I should go this way.
Can't you fast?
Where?
How?
I'll just go this way.
This has to be a... This can't be that slow.
Sounds like a problem for a future dokey to worry about.
At least it's also because we're driving against the
current.
Okay.
I'm just gonna hope that there is some way to...
No, the boost is just...
You get to hover a little bit higher.
So, like, this is literally the boost.
I get to be, like, two centimeters above water.
Like, just two centimeters, just a little bit above water.
I hope I can't.
Oh, my God.
I would be so sad if there is actually, like, no way to get
up top.
Guys, this isn't looking too good right now.
Wait, you're right.
What, Corinne?
I'm hovering.
Wait a minute.
You're right.
No holding back.
I'm going to trust.
Oh, God.
Please tell me there's a way to climb up this.
No, there's no way.
There's no way.
There has to be a hole.
See, there's a hole there.
Maybe this hole will lead up top.
Maybe the ground.
Maybe the grotto will lead to a different hole.
Oh no, it's just or.
It's fine.
Free or.
Free or guys.
I went here for the or.
Okay guys.
I did it for the or.
It was too tough.
You can always run away and live to fight another day.
There has to be.
There has to be an entrance.
There's no way.
Perhaps.
There has to be like a way to go up top.
Not, but I'm telling you, just in case that turns out not to
be true.
Alright, alright, fine.
Guys, I bet you there's a way.
There's a hole here.
There's no way.
Because there's no way there has to be a hole here.
There's a hole, right?
There has to be.
There's no way then let me drive all over here.
If there's a hole, there's a way.
Please, I just, all I want to be is in forest land.
Please.
We might be able to reach these inaccessible spots one day.
What do you mean one day?
What do you mean inaccessible spots one day?
Wait, there's a hole!
I fucking knew it.
Guys, no.
No, no, my ship, my ship is too short.
There's no way.
Oh, thank God.
I knew it.
I knew there was a hole.
Nobody believed me.
That's a sign that someone's been here before us.
Where?
Those are our tracks.
That's a useful location like a village or town.
The cars should also go a bit faster than it would on
unpacked ground.
I knew it, guys.
I knew there was always a way.
We just gotta figure...
Oh.
Guys.
Is there...
Oh, there is.
There is.
There is a checkpoint.
Wait.
Open up.
What do you mean this door is closed?
What do you mean?
Guys.
The door is closed over there.
No!
Maybe we can go around.
Guys, we can go around, guys.
What do you mean?
I'm not supposed to be here.
No!
I was never supposed to be here.
Because...
Because how do I get across?
Wait, me, I was not supposed to be here.
No.
Okay, we're gonna figure it out, guys.
How the fuck?
Wait, if we go across here and then move here, okay.
I figured it out, guys.
I figured it out.
Oh my god.
It's a rare one.
Wait, that's a rare dinosaur.
That's endangered.
I'm the reason why it's endangered.
I wouldn't do that wrong.
Alright.
This way.
This is it.
This is the other checkpoint.
Don't worry.
I got my passport.
ready, guys.
Don't worry.
I got my passport ready.
Yay!
Okay.
Guys, I should have went that way.
That was a lot faster.
Who would have thought?
Who would have thought that was the right way?
Wait, there's another city here?
Oh, that is not a city.
Goodbye.
Sorry, that was definitely not another city.
We're almost there.
Please, one cannot see forest land.
For three parts, I've been baited about forest land.
Should be here.
Something smells like treasure.
Ooh, is he gonna get it?
It should be this way.
Okay.
God, my fucking gun is so weak.
Oh, it's underneath the water.
Whoops.
I almost forgot about the hover car.
It's okay, I got the hover car this time.
I'm sorry, I thought I could drive faster than the water.
Like, those, like, running lizards, you know?
another ruin I just thought it was like those like running
lizards we run so fast you can run above water so I thought
I could bike so fast
whoa there's a swamp here it's like a mangroves it's pretty
maybe it's just a matter of seeing so much water here but
this place seems almost holy to me is this a church you're
making me want to barf my head hurts oh no is there a cross
here oh no oh my god wait what oh it's holy water i'm not
supposed to touch it it's literally holy water there's loot
finally yeah finally a dungeon that's not a factory holy
shit be gone demons i was just thinking right now i just
thought about like any yasha and you guys remember when like
they try to make a sequel to any yasha about like any yasha
any yasha and shishuru's kids and then like people sort of
oh my god there's a giant octopus we're playing zelda and
then like People sort of, like, forgot about it.
Apparently that show didn't do so well either, so, like, no
wonder.
If only we could raise the water level.
Oh, no, this is a puzzle?
A puzzle?
I didn't watch it, so I don't know.
Wait, no, there's, like, no, it's not.
We just walk up.
it i don't know i never watched it i always know like
whenever they make like usually whenever like they use bank
on nostalgia it's oh my god what a puzzle holy the puzzle of
the century
okay but like usually whenever i show banks on nostalgia on
like sequels and stuff it's usually not good like i mean did
you guys see the new foster's home for imaginary friends
sequel that's gonna come up the graphics for that shit looks
really really bad
it's a water temple too lazy to get off no i always have too
lazy to get off the car wait we weren't supposed to be here
oh no it's this way i didn't see the other door
oh my god i'm a mess right now Is this where I'm supposed to
be?
Where is this?
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
Yeah, they're planning on making a sequel for Foster's Home
for Imaginary Friends.
But like, what was it?
Foster's Fun...
Yeah, Foster's Fun Time for Imaginary Friends.
It's a preschool cartoon.
That's when you No, um, what's his name?
Craig had, like, nothing to do with it.
Because, like, I don't think...
There's no way he has anything to...
Like, Craig had anything to do with the preschool version.
I don't think so.
I don't think he would, like, willingly make a preschool
version of the show.
There's a kid's version of Total Drama.
Island?
Holy shit, that's that's like that's like against like the
whole premise of Total Drama!
I've actually never I've never watched Total Drama Island
Confession Time.
I've never watched Total Drama Island.
What's that?
Here we go.
I think like I don't know I just never played on TV when I
Oh that's a big crocodile!
Oh, well, okay, that's a dead crocodile.
Never mind.
Alright.
Yay!
Should have evolved into anti-tank.
You know the world, what the world was like.
If you don't evolve and adapt, you get the kill.
Alright, I think it was this way?
I'm, like, a bit lost right now because I get to soar in
here so easily.
Has to be this way.
Yeah.
Holy shit, that's enough.
a big crocodile it's okay my guns are so strong yay and then
up we go
nice it's good that i don't have to get off the the car what
was what the thing is like the thing about like there it's
crazy to think about but like a lot of like british shows
they don't get sequels they just end i don't know why but a
lot of british tv shows and like cartoons or whatever they
usually just end it after after like one or two seasons and
like they usually have like you know five or six episodes
they don't usually like prolong it like american
syndications yeah and then they get an american version
that's so true and then they get american version that has
like 800 seasons wallace and grommet get a movie Yeah, but
you guys hear Claymation The art form of claymation is like
Might die out Because the main factory That makes claymation
clay Close down I don't know if you guys heard about it It
was like a news a while ago But the main factory That make
like claymation clay Close down because like I don't know if
it was like the creation of it was too old and they don't
know who to pass it down or something or like it was just
not worth manufacturing too high to keep going was that
false I thought it yeah the studios are working off I just
heard I heard like the studio bought like a stockpile of it
yeah they bought up all the remaining the remaining stock of
the claymation clay It's like a super specific, yeah, it's
like a super specific kind of clay.
It happened before with chalk, with like math professors.
With like math professors and chalk because there's like a
very specific chalk that professor use for classes.
Because it's like the best kind of chalk.
And then like the originally the factory, the creator of the
formula was just going to close down.
down because they didn't have like a successor to it yeah
very very specific uh japanese chalk and they were
originally going to like just close down and like have the
formula die with him uh but then he found like a super
passionate like math professor a very passionate nerd about
about like math like chalk in general so then he like passed
down the formula and also like the factory uh to like uh
because like you need apparently you need like a very
specific like equipment to make the chalk so like and only
his factory um only his factory can produce it so like
originally he had like his children didn't want to continue
his children didn't want to continue the legacy because you
know they're like we want to do other things dad we don't
want to be we don't oh my god stop stop this is why i'm so
far so good this is why i have a tank uh but like his kids
didn't want to continue the legacy because you know they're
like i don't want to be a I don't want to be a nerd so then
uh what what do you mean not a good oh I had to wear stairs
in front of me okay what what do you mean let me have my
hover car here we go why can't I call this
okay yeah it's the wait it's the best okay I did not hear
about the best tasting chalk of all time like the best chalk
in the world but yeah so like they had that issue but then
they found a successor i think like from a math professor in
korea right um and then he like um he like gave him like the
fact like the equipment to make the chalk and stuff and then
he's gonna continue he's gonna continue the legacy which is
pretty cool i thought that was really interesting so yeah
that's Basically, what's happening with Claymation?
I don't know if they actually, if they, like, actually, uh,
uh, what's it called?
They, like, uh, found a successor to make the clay now.
Because, like, just like Claymation, it's a very specific
clay.
Uh, that, um, is a very, very specific clay for it.
Like, I remember, like, studios were freaking out and buying
all the remaining clay from the factory.
I hope so too.
I really like claymation in general.
It looks awfully deep.
Let's use the hovercraft.
I've been using the hovercraft this entire time.
What do you mean?
Let's use the hovercraft.
Now get rid of the crocodile population.
Guys, by killing the crocodiles, only the strongest can
survive, and they will adapt to the future.
It can live on.
Oh, hey, nice.
Where's the lever?
This better be the last lever.
I hope so, too.
I hope so, too, Bells.
Where did my cargo?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm giving the Crux immunity to the missiles, guys.
I'm helping the environment.
I'm making it so that they will be immune to missiles in the
future.
So their descendants will, like, evolve.
I mean, yeah, you're right.
They already evolved to survive asteroids.
Now they can evolve to survive missiles.
Is that what we wanted?
Any thoughts for the upcoming King of the Hills sequel?
I don't know how the fuck they're going to be able to
replace Bobby.
I don't know I don't know It's gonna be a weird scene King
of the Hill Being like digital art I feel like a lot of Um I
feel like a lot of Shows The shows that they reboot Reboot
Lose its charm Because they go like Full digital animation
It's not It feels so weird Compared to like Uh Maybe I can't
call the ride here Feels weird compared to like Like uh you
know cell cell what was it called cell animation it was like
every time like uh an an old show like when an old show gets
rebooted or like uh confirm the sequel um and they they
change like animation techniques and stuff it just feels off
key animation was a cell uh yeah they have to recast a lot
of people too That's the thing.
I am so lost.
That's what I'm saying.
Like, they have to replace some voice actors because, you
know, some of them passed away.
Oh!
Oh, okay.
Summit on.
Okay, I'll summit here.
Uh.
Oh, yeah.
No, the Powerpuff Girl reboot?
That shit was fucking wild.
Oh, my God.
Okay, there was this whole controversy.
About that guy.
People were like.
Oh my god.
He did a self insert.
Inserted himself into a Powerpuff girl.
But that was like.
Apparently that was a lie.
If you guys didn't know.
He didn't even.
He.
Like the other staff members.
Inserted him.
As a joke.
And so he didn't.
He.
Yeah.
Yes.
Like apparently.
He didn't even want it to be like.
In the show.
like one of the writers and like apparently like one of some
the animation team uh yeah his friends did that without
telling him which was fucking crazy because like everyone
thought he like inserted himself like he wanted it uh people
thought that like he and like he was doing his self-insert
and was like laughing at him and stuff about it being like
wow i can't believe self-insert and apparently it was just
like a prank apparently but everybody like spread the rumor
being like wow he self-inserted himself that's so creepy and
that story was a lie it was a lie this entire time why was
it creepy because he was like he made that self-insert like
the um like made that self-insert blossom's crush so people
were like wow that's so creepy making yourself a self-insert
and then making blossom crush on you wow and then like the
guy the writer finally came out and was like i didn't even
know i was they're like i it was like i didn't even want to
i i didn't even ask for this they inserted me there without
telling me So his reputation Actually got fucked over As a
joke Oh my god It was actually crazy
It's just a joke A joke in question
Because everyone thought he like put it Put himself in there
Himself That was like the biggest plot twist of my life all
right oh my god what is this oh i can jump this yeah i can
just ride across it because it's like a little podium yeah i
don't even know guys i should have jumped i got too cocky i
got a little too cocky dr cranberry thank you but super chat
thank you thank you the problem with media nowadays is
nobody wants to invest in a risky venture which means we get
less original project which increases remakes and sequels
instead of original risky shows and games thank you thank
you thank you yeah no but if the board doesn't want i why
did i guys i did not learn guys i didn't learn guys i did
okay i need to get off the car i'm not learning that's true
because it's just safer to bank on nostalgia than it is to
like risk um then like risk uh creating a new ip which sucks
because like honestly uh we need new ip because like things
are getting really stale with just i mean i heard the new
star wars sequel is really fucking like not sorry the star
wars spin-off was it the ass or whatever um was really
really bad um so like it makes sense you know
uh oh thank you so much for the 10 shifts thank you thank
you i really appreciate it oh there's another lever oh and
then like pixar made okay you know what's funny pixar i
don't know if you saw the newest statement made by pixar but
pixar made a statement like i think like this week where
they were like guys guys like we're not gonna do live action
i'm like what
like why would you why do you need to make that statement
your pixar so i think like apparently disney is trying like
the disney execs are trying to pressure pixar into doing
live action or something and i'm like why they're pixar why
would they need to do yeah no one expected So I got I was
like confused.
I was like, why does Pixar need to make that statement?
Who expects them to do live action?
Yeah, they aren't doing lives action, but they're doing
500,000 wait.
Oh, I was like, why is your boss music?
Oh, that's why.
Oh, that's a big crocodile.
I was like, who expects you to do live action?
So I think it's like Disney must have tried to pressure him
to do like live-action or something because who expects them
to do a live-action?
It's Pixar
Disney making live-action of all their existing properties.
Yeah, that's that's the thing is some of those movies do
really well Uh, like not in America
How many fucking Leverage do I have to turn on?
Oh, there it is.
Did you guys know there's a...
Did you guys know?
Okay, so you know how there's like a Lilo and Stitch series?
Okay, not Lilo and Stitch.
Sorry.
Stitch series.
Uh, in Japan, right?
I just found out there's a Stitch series like based in
China.
I was so surprised because like, like, that was not like
public knowledge and like in for like people i just found
out about it hey check this out yeah there's a sister's and
it's just like based in china there's something here
something round not another urn is it oh it's you yeah it
was made okay so like the okay let's go through this plot
and then i'll tell you guys the origin of it
Okay, so like Hmm The little the the stitch series in Japan
was not made by the Disney company It was made by like
Madhouse or something Um, it was made by famous Japanese
like animation company Because they wanted to like, um, you
know do the licensing for stitch And then so there but the
the the the stitch series in China was made by the original
was I think was in my house or am I saying it wrong it was
like one of the bigger one of the bigger anime Japanese
animation companies and it was was it madhouse I don't
remember can someone fact-check me oh I'm talking about the
stitch animation series someone can fact-check me you guys
have the internet
Everyone's like Madhouse for real.
Okay, so, yeah, okay, it is.
Okay, yeah, it was a licensing.
Yeah, okay, someone fact checked.
Okay, yeah, it was a, I was right.
Okay, it was a, they had a licensing agreement with
Madhouse.
Because Madhouse wanted to make a Stitch series.
Because Stitch was super popular in Japan.
It did do, but turn around, I guess.
But then, the China version was made by the original
animation studio.
for the Lilo and Stitch series.
Very funny, Grins.
That's just a drainage channel.
But it'll be a really fun ride, right?
You're absolutely not!
Yeah, like the original...
And they got the original director for Lilo and Stitch.
Like the TV show series.
And the movies.
Like the Leroy and Stitch, the very first Lilo and Stitch
movie.
I mean, the second side.
the second Lilo and Stitch movie and everything.
They actually got like the original like director to make
the the version for based in China.
And I was like so surprised because like I never heard about
that.
I've never heard about the version based in China.
I literally found out like this week because it showed up in
my recommended because I was like what?
It was apparently only shown in.
Oh wait.
Oh I have to hover.
Whoops.
Oh that's what the feature was for like everybody knows the
Japanese version and everybody knows the English you know of
course everybody knows the English version so I was like I
just found out about it and it was like that the series
released like in 2017 oh God whoops all right it doesn't
matter wait I don't even lose HP like what doesn't matter.
Okay, I know about the Powerpuff Girls.
I knew about the Powerpuff Girls anime.
Which is funny, because in the Powerpuff Girls anime,
they're not even siblings.
It's just a magical girl anime.
They found, and it's like three random girls.
And Professor Utonium has a fucking son.
Yeah, I like PPG, you see.
Powerpuff Girls Z was good.
I watched it.
Of course I watched it.
It was a really good show.
I'm worried about what's been making all that racket.
Oh my god, is it a giant crocodile?
Let's call it out and see what it is.
It has to be a boss.
It looks like a boss.
Is it a giant octopus?
Oh, it has to be giant octopus because of the shrine.
With horns.
Oh, you've done it now.
God, I love the 3D models for this game, though.
I love how it's just based.
Like, the Toriyama style is just so noticeable.
Oh, it's a squid!
It's looking this way.
Whoops.
Forget it.
Let me handle this.
Alright, let me handle this, I say, as I just...
Can I summon Raul?
Put that tank in there!
Nice.
Yeah, stay there!
Wait, I can literally...
Oh, ow.
It's fine.
We're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
Everything's fine.
Oh, it's okay.
It's just a little damage.
It's okay if anything bad happens, We can literally just,
uh, just swap to a tank.
Wait, where did he go?
Shit, no, really?
Oh my god, if it's not hurting it, we would be in so much
trouble.
That's all I'm saying.
It better be hurting it, Raul.
I hope so.
It would be awkward.
if it's not.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my god.
Bro, okay, I'm fucking bringing up the tank.
There's no way.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I'm bringing up the tank.
I feel like the tank is stronger, right?
Ow.
It's fine.
Oh, my god.
It just barely does any damage.
I can literally take this.
Guys, I can literally...
I can literally just stand here.
This fucking squid does nothing.
Look at that.
It's just a fucking slap.
Okay, never mind.
That took a lot of damage actually.
Never mind.
It's okay.
It'll heal himself.
I have the cutscene heal.
The cutscene will heal me.
Ow.
Don't worry, the cutscene will heal me.
Look, see, half HP.
Nothing to worry about.
Oh, where did he go?
Oh, shit.
Like, what am I supposed to do?
Yeah, don't worry.
I'm not worried.
Okay, I'm just a sad here.
I only have to move when it comes to, like, the big guy.
The slap sound, yeah.
Oh.
I mean, I can literally just stand here for this one.
I feel like I don't have to actually have to worry about
these guys.
No!
Sorry, I walked into the water.
I forgot my tank cannot swim, guys.
The most crucial, important information.
I can't swim.
Okay.
We're not swimming.
One good shot to do it.
Really?
Where?
Ow.
Please, squid, come out!
More!
Oh my god.
Okay, fuck it.
It's just easier.
It's just easier at this point to get this over with.
Get over here.
Where are you?
Oh, here.
so wait my other car was doing actually more damage oops
oops was not paying attention wait he only shoots one and
leave there you go woo okay come on that's right you can't
catch me i'm hovering
yeah but the tank was tankier exactly oh god god damn He
hits me and then he leaves.
He hit and runs.
That's fucked up.
What?
Where did he go?
Okay, nice.
Got him.
He's so close to dying.
He's literally one hit.
He's two hits.
Sorry, I can't count.
No!
Okay, nice.
Oh my god, where is he coming up?
Yes!
we did it coward why can't you take the hits like i did
god damn coward
oh no he's gonna drown oh
my god we're here where the heck am i oh my god i'm eating
but we're here i don't recognize this smell
We're finally here!
I told you it's not Glen Bay!
Where's Leaf and the old man?
Looks like...
I told you, Forestland was real, guys!
After 200 years, we finally made it!
It's real!
There's...
monkeys!
Marshall, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I told you it wasn't clickbait!
It existed!
There's actual trees!
Oh my god, and there's loot.
I'm gonna yonk all that loot.
Nice.
Mine now.
It's real!
You guys thought I was crazy, but I knew trees existed.
I can't believe it.
No more sand.
Now let's ruin the environment.
With a tank.
Finally what I wanted to do all this time.
Green!
Thank you for the super chat.
Nova, thank you.
Thank you.
Time to turn this into a desert.
Come on out.
It's useless to hide from a fiend.
Fiend?
A real demon?
Holy shit.
What's wrong with your face?
Is this what?
Just look at all of you crawling out of the woodwork.
Oh my god.
These people have belts.
Really are a demon.
What are demons doing in forest land?
Nigel Thornberry.
We're in forest land?
No shit, Basil.
Bob, what do you think this is?
Wow, this is awesome.
I've never seen a demon before.
Why is he like a surfer, bro?
He does not look like a surfer.
Okay, not gonna lie.
the male number three seems to have the wrong voice acting
you think this is a safari surround them we can't just stand
by and let these filthy demons invade our home
don't tell me you guys are part of the forest land army too
it doesn't matter if it's a fight you want i'll give you one
well male number one Whoa!
Oh, wait.
Okay.
That's fucking right.
You should not have pissed me off.
Big mistake.
No!
He touched me!
It's all over!
I told shit!
No!
Demon kudos!
We have to protect our country We can't let these despicable
monsters Corrupt our home Say that again You little Whoa
whoa whoa PG 13 Raul Look the monkeys The monkey's like
What's going over here guys Whoa Hey what did you see that
Looks like you ran a little wild That'll teach him mess with
the fiend prince i say they could do with more punishment
please i beg you forgive them elderly person's voice who are
you yeah who are you allow me to introduce myself i am long
ago their commander that's a lot of jail is that the king he
helped me and thief when we washed ashore we owe him
huh my apologies for my youthful comrades it's like a little
umbrella you can make like has anyone ever made like a hair
umbrella head to a demon that's enough Udo
your disrespect toward our guests beggars belief Jeff you
made these demons you're not thinking of recruiting them to
the resistance this has to be the king right the
re-assistance come aren't these the guys that hate demons
just this further on the way
all right let's go continue with continue on with lango my
sincere apologies mr biazza oh my god there's purple raptors
i told you guys the raptors were invasive species.
They came from forest land.
I was doing my job.
I knew it.
I fucking knew they were invasive.
They came from the forest.
This is Florida.
She was right.
They are like the iguanas.
no there's no way as a sand lander there's no way these the
raptors came from us it has to be from the forest
they see i bought trains him how do we move forward again
all right thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
remember to have your lights on oh wait there's a chest here
yoink my chest now oh wait i didn't pick it up i i fucking
knew it you guys thought i was crazy when i told you about
the invasive species you guys were like don't you know think
about the animal right but i knew it i knew they were
invasive the floridians were right
Wait, I'm going... Oh, no, I'm going the right way.
Okay.
I should use the bike now.
To try to determine the princess's location.
Once they discover where she was taken, we will devote all
our forces to the task of freeing her.
See?
The peddler has a blue racker.
I fucking knew it.
See?
They even have their own cats!
I knew the cats were invasive species, too!
the cats survive in the sand i knew it there's no cats in
the set there's no cats in sand i knew it all along i was
right all along they all came from forest land
every single one of them we'll get kill them just just in
advance i knew it sand lands aren't real.
Now that's why I knew that sad cats weren't real.
There's always an origin.
No.
They don't exist.
That's just propaganda.
Spread by the forest landers.
No, there's no...
I don't know what you guys are talking about.
Desert cats never existed.
They're just propaganda spread by the forest landers.
train on the assumption that war could break out at any
moment that mindset alone might explain the difference in
strength between them and the royal army all right we gotta
go where is it oh it's this way no exactly they seem to be
very well informed I'm someone who failed to protect his
kind and just king in his time of need what the fuck who are
you the most I managed to do for with his young innocent
daughter.
Just a feeble old man, really.
Not so feeble.
I refuse to believe you're a feeble old man.
Hey, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Whoa, sand cats are a real thing.
And they are the most adorable wild cats out there.
Thank you for the super chat.
You pay with pay with your forest land money.
Brought to you by the king of forest land.
planning were there no he has to be the king see
I told you it's starting the forest land propaganda is
already starting bread hoping to achieve through his coup d
'etat and thought he just wanted to seize more territory for
forest land how do you seize more territory for forest land
and all the forest is yours yeah that's something the four
of us would like to know more about to the poorest agenda
what was that about how you'd never join forces with us
they're trying to plague trees that are sad we can't let
them we can't let their disgusting trees touch our precious
sand you heard about big pharma this is big tree time.
Are you gonna turn to a request from an old comrade?
Huh?
So this old man was in your- You're thinking I'll send.
No, I was in the rebel army.
You were in the rebel army.
You're not even a sand- I knew it.
I- no sand lander would try to swim in sand land.
I fucking knew it.
What kind of sand ladder you're trying to swim?
I know how formidable an enemy you make.
I'm glad to have you as an ally instead.
The reason he was so strong is because he had a swimmers on
his side.
Papa, your face is all red.
Is anybody a real sand ladder?
Who's even from sand ladder at this rate?
is to gather up the last five extant Aquanium capsules in
the world and use them to restart Garum the flying fortress
the flying fortress where the fuck did that come from yeah
same route same the former peachy mothership which landed in
flatland so many years ago there's a flatland bro what what
What does Flatland have?
After being modified for battle, it's said to have been the
world's most powerful warship.
Another land?
What does Flatland even have?
It's unclear how much of this is true.
But rumor has it that it took only three days for its
terrible weapons to send Flatland.
The world's wealthiest, most advanced nation.
Oh my god, Flatland's Atlantis!
Now is Ocean Land.
It's better than even Zayu's Fortress?
Without a doubt, if its capabilities require five times the
Aquanium to power, what will they do if they ever manage to
get it working again?
The Forest Land made sure of it.
Winners write the history books.
Flatland never exists.
Existed bring the world to its knees To hell with that flat
lances I share that sentiment which is why we Longo Where
the fuck is Udo?
It's male number one, excuse me.
Oh, no, he's I have urgent business.
Yeah, and to I will probably be occupied for some time.
Male number one has a name now.
Rest up in the meantime.
We'll take you up on that.
We're awful tired from swimming here.
Let's make the rounds of the camp.
We should take the chance to gather whatever intelligence we
can.
All right.
I can't believe it.
We just found out about Flatland.
Only for Flatland to never exist in To not exist anymore.
It became ocean land.
The Atlantis of Flatland.
We don't need that.
Oh, he can upgrade my stuff.
Hey.
Yeah, I want to upgrade.
Okay, we can actually upgrade our parts now.
I feel like that's something we haven't really done.
Wait, actually, let's make sure our vehicle has all the
parts we need.
Um...
I like the damage it does so Let's see Oh wait that's new
Outrigger Enables rapid fire at the cost of mobility No we
need defense We really need defense Alright let's see Let's
upgrade our part Because I feel like We have not done that
at all Okay because we still can't Never mind let's not do
that I guess we just don't Give Forestland a chance They did
nothing wrong Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Spoken like a true propagandist.
Golden, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Flatland is known for its justice and cutting voice.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Set the forest lander.
Are there even real forest landers in this world?
Okay, let's go.
Where do we go?
There's like two different ways.
Oh, there's this guy.
And Chapone.
Oh my god, you have a male number two has a name!
The forest ladders spot it.
Cowed by the prince's might, are you?
Don't get ideas.
I need the one sir was right
Okay, okay, I think that's enough By the way, do you know
anything about the flying fortress Garum?
Well, I'm just a new recruit, so I can't say I know much Oh,
he's a newbie Udo says activating it would be like
restarting the war that nearly destroyed the world years ago
there's another war i have a hard time seeing it as some
terrifying doomsday weapon but if uddo says so so it's
capable of destruction that would make the bomb that all but
wiped out the peachy look like a firecracker wait there was
another war how many wars were there i had the peachy war
and then there's like a different one oh it's the same war
just happened Mac, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Flatland enjoyed a time of great peace until the Forest
Nation attack.
Until...
Oh, what's this?
Pirateship.
Nice.
Okay, Kishima.
Oh my god, mail number three!
You're not generic characters who actually all have names.
Not really.
It's pretty hard to tell all you humans apart.
hmm so demons have difficulty distinguishing humans how do
you have difficulty distinguishing this guy what are you
doing taking notes well um you know knowledge is power
especially for wimps like me whoa bro be kind to yourself
man i'm a royalist i want king jam back in charge of this
one here would say the same and that's reason enough to lay
down your life for him i mean you lay down your life for
your prince right fascinating so demons struggle with the
idea of self-sacrifice there why that's not true at all i'd
gladly give my life yeah lucifer i thought you'd give his
life for me look you're a prince not a king the king can
have more children but we can't have another I suppose I'd
at least lay down my whiskers for you I mean at this rate
that okay not gonna lie at the rate that demons are aging
like It's gonna take fucking forever for them to grow up to
be a to be like old enough to be a king Okay At least the
king is like actually an adult I don't know how many more
years after way for biz above to fucking be an adult Here we
go Okay Okay, I'll go this way.
Can't believe it.
It's so weird not to see sad in the sad land game.
Guys, run faster.
That was like...
That took so long to run.
You look agitated.
We found the princess.
The light jog.
Long goes in the command center.
Heard that prince.
Let's go see Long.
Longo!
Sure.
How would a sister be?
Well, I mean, she's Lilith.
Lilith is considered the first demon.
In lore history.
In lore.
I know that from Supernatural.
So, like, if Lilith's the first demon, then like, obviously,
like, she's old, old.
Let's see.
It's this way.
You said you found Dan?
Rosetta's tank brigade has stopped at Endmill Base to the
northeast.
The resistance will set out in pursuit with all possible
enemies.
Lucifer was a fallen angel.
If you're only the Lesser Hand, please head to the base as
well.
Yeah, I know my demon lore.
I used to watch Supernatural.
And also Aspen Hotel.
We don't talk about that one.
Okay.
Biblical history is not an add-in game.
Okay, let's see.
We gotta...
What do you say?
Oh, I'm talking about Super NES.
true oh god thank you now jim boo wait you're here too what
i mean i have a lot but where are these places what the is
the mopping region any rare items you find i'll make it
worth your while all right we go this way where is it my god
it's a whole new land let's see wait i can't call a rod
right now I have to use my legs?
No!
I have to use my legs like a peasant?
I am a prince.
I can't believe it.
Like these regular people.
Damn it.
I'm going to ride the fucking dinosaur at this rate.
Oh my god.
I have to use my legs like the commoners.
Like the humans.
I can't believe it.
My feet should not be touching the dirty ground.
What do you mean?
They're literally the same creatures, but different colors.
Like, what?
What?
Like, what do you mean?
They're literally, like, the same kind of creature.
different colors.
The sand cat.
The forest land cat is brown instead of black.
And then the raptors are like purple instead of red.
Apparently the blue.
The blue raptors are everywhere apparently.
What the fuck?
Oh that's a monkey.
I was like what the fuck is that?
We don't need ores guys.
Okay now I should be able to ride my bike.
Get away.
My bike is faster.
I'm sorry raptors.
But my bike is a lot faster.
Oh, no.
I didn't wear a helmet.
It must be densely populated.
What's that?
Is that human?
Oh, that's humans.
That was a human.
Sorry, I don't see monkeys in sad land.
So it's like, it's an actual new species for me.
I was like, whoa!
That exists?
Wait, what's over there?
It has to be, like, loot.
Usually, they're loot.
Alright.
Get over here.
Yay!
Free stuff!
Vegetation makes for easy ambushes.
That's certainly something to keep in mind when in the
jungle.
Oh, I got poisonous mushrooms?
Oh, my God.
All right, what can I do with a poisonous mushroom?
It's this way.
And where do I go?
Oh, I have to go back here anyway.
All right.
Now I'm curious what other lands they have.
Because, you know, I thought they would, like, follow the
conventional naming sequence they gave us.
Like, you know, sand land.
And you would think the next land would be like ocean land
or something or like, I don't know something.
Oh, wait, what's this?
Whoa!
Who are you?
Mountain land.
Cave land.
Yeah, shit like that.
And then we get flat land.
Like, what?
Okay, Flatland was the plot twist for me.
I was not expecting.
Or, like, you know, Snowland, Snowland, Iceland, but then
there's...
Now that they introduced Flatland, then there could be,
like, Jagged Land, Bumpy Land.
Fighting on uneven terrain, always gain the high ground
before your opponent.
Like, now there's, like, Bouncy Land.
But a royal pain to hit someone from low ground.
There's so many different lends.
We gotta go up.
Up we go.
I'm so happy we're finally here.
I don't have to see sand anymore.
Took forever to get here.
This way?
Alright, nice.
holy shit how far away is it this is a whole new air oh my
god this map is actually huge that's why it was destroyed it
didn't fit the criteria of what a land was
oh my god there's roads guys they have actual roads they're
so advanced vegetation so it's hard to see and easy to
defend oh my god my car can i forgot guys i forgot i don't
get fall damage but my car gets fall down goodbye
oh my gosh i forgot my car gets fall down wait okay it's
okay it's okay it's not like it's we don't have to go back
too much all right don't don't drive off the cliff this time
as long as i don't drive off the cliff we'll be fine chat i
learned wait what's that soldiers are pretty tough i bet
they train on the assumption that war could break out at any
moment that's up that mindset alone might explain the
difference in strength
they're they're like an actual military oh the swimmers are
here how did they get here so fast hello guys hey guys guys
are so fast you really did show up of course you got a
problem with that got to help and although i sort of just
want to keep polak Polak is a better ad.
What's the situation?
As bad as it could get.
Supreme Commander Bred just arrived at Endmill Base.
We believe he's there to take custody of Anne.
A missing princess suddenly returns a decade later.
I can see how that would merit the attention of the Supreme
Commander himself.
What happens if he does take her with him?
She'll become a figurehead to prop up the literature.
legitimacy of bread's rule or else a scapegoat to turn the
people against the royalists either way she'll be nothing
but a pawn then we have to get the princess back just let
her just escape again she's so good at just running away
since bread's arrival we stand no chance if we try to take
them head on mr row how would you approach this problem
simple divide and conquer We have the bulk of our forces
draw the enemy's attention while a small crack of our forces
mean like two of us
Where's the bulk?
There's literally like ten of us here Doug, thank you for
the super chat.
Thank you.
Look at the fortress.
They have men.
They have torrents They literally have like turrets on the
castle.
What do you mean the bulk?
All of us.
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What's this?
Well-paid roads, fresh trees and water, a functioning
society?
This is all forest land propaganda.
Don't believe the lie.
How do you choose for the stealth operation?
You want a crack squad?
You can't get more crack than the swimmer.
They have satellite TV.
What the fuck?
If you want a crack fighter, you come to me.
Bro, bro, I thought it was like being a Satellander.
It's a good thing anymore We don't have time to argue I'll
choose the teams myself Mr. Rao Will you command the
infiltration team?
Of course Guys, I think I want to be a foreshadow, guys
Guys, the propaganda's working chat I saw the satellite And
not you And not you either
We can't delay a moment longer.
It's time to move I feel like I feel like Forest Land is
like the UK and the Sand Land is Australia and the Forest
Land like ship the criminals to Sand Land because like they
don't even have the junker they don't even have like the
junkers here.
We're heading out.
Here we go.
Let's see.
It's like the origin of Australia.
you what the fuck is going on here oh shit what the fuck bro
grandpa's tank bro guys that's that's the bulk of our forces
guys guys the book of our forces is doing it all five of
them lots of soldiers in this area keep a close eye on your
surroundings All right, don't worry, I'm keeping close eye.
Oh, wrong way.
There's like no security.
The bulk of our forces dragged like the five other people's
getting in for this land.
Just enters through the front.
Yeah, that's my security.
We did it.
That was easy.
We'll attract too much attention if all three of us move
together.
split up prince we'll use your telepathy to communicate okay
well i forgot i have that power dare suddenly go in our
heads to make us jump yeah yeah i guess it's like you know
like a dozen as well so like a ball in like in like the
sandland world's term oh in like sandland world terms A bulk
is like five Whoops, I forgot about I forgot about the
sneaking part of this game
Wait, oh there's a guy here Wait, this is actually difficult
No If I just walk up this way
Oh, what?
Sorry, I didn't see you I thought I could kill him It's
okay.
No, I got this guy.
Watch this.
Watch this, guys.
And then, sneak, sneak, sneak, sneak, sneak, sneak, sneak.
Sneak, sneak, sneak, sneak, sneak, sneak, sneak.
There you go.
Nice, I scared him to death.
All right.
See, it's that easy.
Look, he can't see me if I just...
No!
He can see ahead of you!
way I can't believe it you could see like five feet ahead he
has eyes there's no way it should be illegal
so he can't see five feet ahead that's not fair turn around
turn around turn around Turn around.
Turn around.
He's just making up lies.
Yeah.
I don't know what he said, but yeah.
I was busy trying to sneak through here.
Oh my god, please crawl faster.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
Don't turn around.
Okay, we gotta sneak up, and then we should make it.
Get over here.
Nice.
All right.
Now we can run.
Yeah!
We made it.
Can I throw in my tank now?
I am sure you require no explanation.
That's a lot of people.
It's the power to combat and vanquish feasts.
And as luck would have it, oh, he looks like that Gundam
character.
For he is the same hero who Struck down the feed that
beguiled our former king Our king will be none other than
our champion the valiant moon yeah,
I was gonna say your sister lost to that
There's no way.
We left this child here.
Oh my god.
Sorry, I'm listening to his voice.
Can't wait to try them out.
But guess now isn't the time.
Sounds like a fucking weed.
whoa guess i won't go that way wait can i drop down
no guys get the clear war on sandland guys
oh my god okay to be fair it's not even gonna be like much
of a challenge against like sandland like looking comparing
like you know what they have versus what we have like i mean
at least we have demons i guess like we have demons in
sandland on our side can you open it not a problem oh hey
there's anne hey anne i probably shouldn't go too crazy
inside the base why would you want sandland for like do you
you really want the the territory of sandland All we have is
sand.
Aren't we supposed to share an emotional...
You literally have trees and water.
We just got water like two days ago.
Ew, gross.
Alright, let's hurry up and get out of here.
Our people are always dehydrated, yeah.
Wait, can we stop by the command center?
Why?
The command center?
What do you need to go there for?
Imagine on the glass you can...
me that's where the aquanium radar guys we have we have we
have the people in forest land needs their glass really
that's well worth a visit then I object the command center
must have the heaviest security in this whole base not well
bread and mooniel are busy giving their speech there is a
shortage of glass it's the only way then let's go hey time
to time to go go grab time to go grab the queenium radar
wait does that make go downstairs
oh there's no nothing downstairs That's a lot.
If you put a downstairs, you should have at least one chest
downstairs.
What the fuck is this bullshit?
Security's tight here.
We'll be spotted if we move together.
Are we splitting up?
So we split up?
A split up gang.
It's always worked in Scooby-Doo.
Oh, okay.
They're all gone.
All right.
That's cool.
That was fast, but okay.
All right, gang.
We split up so fast.
Wait, what?
There's no point in me doing that.
Here we go!
They looked up!
Prepare for trouble and make it double!
They can look up!
What if I go up?
This is the speedrun strat, guys.
Wait, it is.
Okay.
to do was i go this way here we go and i'll go this way and
then i'll run i told you it's a speedrun strap some soldiers
noticed the tip of my hair poking out from cover i was
almost spotted maybe you shouldn't have spiked it up so
stupidly tall what do you mean stupid this is the
made it to the rendezvous where who else has their hair like
that that's what fashion is if you're the only one wearing
that it's not fashion all right yay elevators at least they
also have elevators all right where the fuck is the radar i
don't i feel like there's gonna be a boss right here later
we're gonna come back here after we pick up the radar and
we're gonna have to fight somebody it's avon card they're
intruders show the alarm yes sir that's such a tiny gun what
the where did he get that gun damn it look at all the glass
behind them you're right guys guys they We need it for this.
Oh, let's get...
But first, the radar.
Where's the radar?
Yeah, I remember.
I think she may be on to something.
Look, it's moving towards another one.
There's another one?
And...
Here.
Wait, how many equaniums do they have?
Now you know where all the equaniums...
Holy shit!
It's the red all equanium?
What the we had to Oh my god, that's a lot
Why did they need to steal from us?
Wait, what's the point of stealing from our stash?
We had to they have like 80
Nice stand down Bread.
Bread.
So even legends age.
Oh my god.
He's so strong.
How is he stronger than a demon?
What?
He's a match for the prince?
Are you really human?
Yeah, that's what I'm seeing.
It's like Tekken.
If that's all you've got, I don't know what people so fear.
Don't test your luck against!
Just be Prince!
It's like Tekken.
He's a sad boy!
Is this real?
Not just my face.
I lost half of my body.
In battle with that whore.
wretched commander ziggler whoa
half how is he alive because he's a cyborg he's like cyborgs
have to lose half is too much human anyway bro he's a cyborg
he can use his fucking cyborg eyes did you see that prince
my quick I just fall down?
No, I can't!
That's fucked up.
Ow!
I can't believe I can't just fall down.
Okay, now I can jump, right?
No!
It's forcing me to use stairs!
That's it.
If I have to use stairs, nobody said I can't bring my tank.
No!
The stairs are not...
wide enough It's so messed up the stairs are not wide
enough.
It's too thick That's it.
I'm bringing the hover car
I'm bringing the hover car if I can't fucking take my take
I'll just bring the other car The stairs I can't believe it
what happened to access this accessibility It's not
accessible with my tank.
They don't care.
They just keep on coming.
They're anti-tanks.
We're getting nowhere.
Prince, you handle things here.
Are you going to do it, Ralph?
Knowing him, he'll leave us behind his bait and escape on
his own.
Who do you think I am?
I'll take care of him.
Yeah.
Don't worry, I brought a car.
That's fucking right.
I paid so much money for this.
Okay, there you go.
Wait, that's a tank.
Wait, how strong is...
Okay, I'm going to bring him out.
Wait, actually, no, these are like T-Mu tanks.
We dropship this tank.
So we're fine.
Yay!
Oh, shit.
Maybe we're not fine.
Wait, maybe I can bring the T-Mu.
over now.
Okay, let's see how strong.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Our tank is strong.
Our tank is stronger.
Alright.
Get out of here.
Wait, what else is there?
Who else is still alive?
Oh, you!
Get out!
Nobody loves you!
Oh, I went the wrong way.
Wait, what?
How do I get there?
No, I was going the right way.
It was the right side.
Sorry, the green means go.
Green means go, guys.
Leave her!
What are you doing, dummy?
Sorry.
Surrender, demons.
Wait, where did they come from?
Whoa, are you okay, Rao?
Whoa!
Hey, those are the Dragon Ball bots!
Sorry for the wait.
It's the awesome bot I wanted to drive.
That's the Dragon Ball Z robot.
The yoke's way too sluggish for my taste.
Really?
Alright!
okay how do i do this battle armor boost jump jump while
hover why does this bot has like 200 instruction okay i can
carry i can melee i can ready weapon i can oh my i can guard
oh my god this is a fighting game now i can throw okay all
right okay there you go all we're gonna do is Alright, I'm
just gonna...
Nice.
Okay, how do I reload?
Okay, I'm gonna reload my...
reload it.
Oh, shit!
That's right.
I'm gonna fight you!
Wait, shooting is faster.
Guys, you can literally try to seize the two people behind
you.
Literally those two kids behind you pick them up all right i
want to see how strong okay how strong is my melee though
boom holy okay that's strong all right pressure broken
she's back and less prejudice actually managed to save her
She's learned!
That's me!
Oh, are you hurt?
No, I'm fine.
But my necklace was stolen.
It's an heirloom passed down in the royal family for
generations.
It has to be like, I bet you has a key to the Flying
Fortress.
All that matters is that you're safe.
It looks like a key.
Come now.
It is time to go home.
Yeah.
Weird.
I get the feeling we're forgetting about someone.
We're forgetting.
Nah.
Yay!
Alright.
Time to fast travel.
Thank God.
way we're forgetting people I'm home everyone oh welcome
back you're hungry I can whip you up something real quick
where are the other ladies in this village she only just got
back wait a minute where are all the other women
She attracts people to her And puts smiles on their faces
There you go, I wonder why When she's the only lady here
Yeah, she's the universe of Smurfette She's probably still
upset About her necklace being stolen on the inside
Makes sense God
there is There you are!
Where did you guys come from?
Wait, there's more!
Oh, thank God.
Where did all these people come from?
Who the fuck are these?
Aren't these guys?
Oh, hello.
Oh, my God!
I've asked and they spawned them in for me!
Oh, hello.
Thank God.
As the Princess Fan Club rep, I offer you my sincerest
things.
Oh, my God.
Thank God, guys.
I mean, it's not as balanced, but still.
Alright, we're gonna call it here, chat.
We rescued and we still have, like, 50 more hours.
Honestly, I don't know how much more we have of this game.
Pretty sure, plenty more.
We're gonna call it here, because we have another stream
tonight.
Alright, let me swap off real quick.
Where's my...
chatting period oh my god we have we still have another
stream uh another stream today so we're gonna call it here i
don't want to overdo it before uh overdo it before today's
stream but that was fun glad we made some progress uh we
made some progress today and um and we advanced the plot and
we finally made it to forest land guys It took us so long,
but we did it, everybody.
Forestland.
I told you, it was not clickbait.
We finally made it.
Honestly, okay, I'm going to check how much more we have of
Sandland.
I'm actually curious.
Because, like, I know, like, tomorrow.
not tomorrow sorry next week uh we won't be able to we won't
be able to uh what's the word um have a have two two two
days of uh sandland for next week because like our schedule
is low-key sort of booked uh i mean i could check around i'm
gonna check my schedule for next week for the good night
dragoons um because like it's gonna take a while to finish
this all right sandland full game all right sandland full
game let's see let's see how where i'm at from this guy's
playthrough all right this guy oh shit guys wait okay we're
at the we're we're at we're technically at the 10 hour mark
guys we're like at the 10 hour mark and this guy took 17
hours to finish this so technically this for them it took
them seven hours for me maybe like 15
okay for us i won't be surprised if it's longer because i'm
just gonna let you guys know um for them this To get to
where I was to like to get to like my when I started this
playthrough versus to where I was at That took us four hours
for the playthrough it took them like two hours so like you
can tell we're like two hours behind We're we're a little
bit behind chat just just a little bit right a little bit
behind we still we still got it guys it's not that it's not
that man like it's still doable um but yeah i still i still
enjoy satin land quite a lot like like i said i really do
like the story of satin land so i don't really mind like you
know we you don't normally see me play jrpgs so it's a nice
change of pace you know just having a jrpg uh like uh to go
back to go to uh michael thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you force land has women all right i'm so thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you cause me can't
wait for the turn good night dragons thank you thank you
thank you yes we have good night dragons tonight uh so
there's more yapping for everybody um but i'm gonna call it
here everyone because like i said uh we do have another
stream today and i don't want to waste not waste what's the
word i don't want to use up all my energy for tonight so
i'll see you guys there i hope you guys enjoyed today's
playthrough of sandland as always everybody stay hydrated
posture check get up and move around to get that blood
flowing and if you set up for me head to bed because you
deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys